[Musik]
hallo zusammen wir gehen live mit zdf
heute live jetzt gleich in den nächsten
minuten wollen spd grüne und fdp ihren
koalitionsvertrag für eine ampel
regierung vorstellen das wäre dann die
erste in der geschichte der
bundesrepublik auf bundesebene und
diesen hermann kant fast schon sagen
historischen moment wollen wir natürlich
begleiten zusammen mit meiner kollegin
der hauptstadtkorrespondenten in nicole
diekmann in berlin mit dem
politikwissenschaftler karl rudolf korte
und später dann auch mit der friday
future klimaschutz aktivistin luisa
neubauer ihnen allen können sie ihre
fragen schicken können sie ihre
kommentare posten und wir werden dann
versuchen so viel wie irgendwie geht
davon zu beantworten jetzt fangen wir
erstmal an mit nicole diekmann hallo
nicole
hallo schöne grüße aus berlin schön dass
sobald uns bist also vielleicht mal ganz
kurz zusammengefasst der ablauf soll
jetzt folgender sein zuerst soll es ein
fototermin geben und dann soll der
koalitionsvertrag vorgestellt werden da
hat unsere kollegin christiane hübscher
vielleicht können wir das mal ganz kurz
zeigen gerade schon getwittert
dass der koalitionsvertrag per qr-code
kommt in grün gelb oder rot was man halt
gerne lieber hätte aber noch ist er
nicht freigeschaltet aber dafür haben
wir dich nicole was ist denn vorab schon
bekannt
da haben wir als journalistinnen und
journalisten in einer mischung aus
ehrfurcht großer überraschung und
totaler genervtheit auf das gepackt was
dann nach außen drang das war nämlich
ungefähr gar nichts im vergleich zu
vorherigen koalitionsverhandlungen und
jetzt ist schon einiges durchgesickert
du hast es ja gerade schon angedeutet
zum beispiel der ressortzuschnitt die
ressort zuteilung und das ist ja total
beliebt auch schon seit wochen wer
kriegt was also fangen wir mal an es
soll sechs ministerien inklusive
kanzleramt geben klar für die spd ich
glaube olaf scholz könnte man als
gesetzt betrachten als bundeskanzler an
die grünen sollen fünf ministerien gehen
und vier ministerien gehen an die fdp
dem vernehmen nach was neu geschaffen
wird ist ein eigenes ministerium für
bauen
mietern
erschwingliche mieten das ist ja etwas
was sich die ampel auf die fahnen
schreibt als großes ziel ihrer politik
dafür nun also anscheinend ein eigenes
ministerium dass wir hören an die spd
gehen soll was es nicht gibt ist ein
eigenes digital ministerium das soll dem
ressort verkehr zugeschlagen sein
ähnlich wie im moment auch schon dieses
ressort wiederum soll soll an die fdp
gehen in einer stunde wissen wir
vermutlich mehr nach der pressekonferenz
konferenz und soll an volker wissing
gehen stand jetzt
okay so viel für den moment werfen wir
mal vielleicht einen blick in das
westhafen events & convention center in
berlin vielleicht haben wir das kurz mal
zeigen da findet die pressekonferenz
gleich statt ok ich kann es auch sagen
weil eigentlich sieht man noch nichts
hier warten die ersten pressevertreter
schon aber es ist noch niemand
aufs podest getreten nicole man hört
soll ja gestern noch sehr sehr spät
geworden sein was wurde da warum worüber
wurde da gestern nacht noch gerungen
das ist auch reine spekulation aber wir
wissen ja wo die zankäpfel in dieser
koalition in dieser total ungewöhnlichen
koalition auf bundesebene eben der ampel
grüne spd und fdp liegen zum einen ist
dass das thema klima zum anderen war
dass das thema finanzierung man hat sehr
viel vor modernisierung ist ein wort das
immer wieder genannt wurde das auch in
den ersten notizen die wir jetzt
zugespielt bekommen haben
zu lesen ist und dafür muss das geld ja
irgendwo herkommen vor allem eben auch
in corinna zeiten ja unvorhergesehene
riesige summen
investiert werden müssen ausgegeben
werden müssen aufgebracht werden müssen
da muss aber dazu sagen auch wenn man
gestern
lange zusammen gesessen hat und auch
eigentlich schon mal so hatte
durchblicken lassen dass man den
koalitionsvertrag schon früher hätte
präsentieren wollen diesen zeitplan
nicht eingehalten hat das bisher alles
total straff wir haben noch nicht mal
dezember in der nikolaus woche das user
der juso slogan lautet ja nikolaus ist
coco aus in der nikolaus woche sei
tatsächlich
olaf scholz als kanzler vereidigt werden
und die ampel tatsächlich die
regierungsgeschäfte übernehmen
das ist sehr sehr schnell
die nacht nummer für uns zusammengefasst
johanna sagt meister hat für uns
zusammengefasst wie der weg denn bis zum
heutigen tag gelaufen ist zur erinnerung
das schauen wir uns vielleicht noch mal
kurz über
den zeitplan sind sich die parteien nach
der bundestagswahl schnell einig bis
weihnachten soll die regierungsbank
gefüllt seien unklar allerdings noch wer
hier platz nehmen wird
mit diesem foto setzen fdp und grüne
zwei tage nach der bundestagswahl ein
deutliches signal
ohne uns geht's nicht sie starten mit
den sogenannten vor sondierungen und
liegen eine regel fest die die gesamten
koalitionsgespräche prägen soll
deutlich gemacht dass sich 2017 nicht
wiederholen soll das heißt dass per live
ticker aus vertraulichen gesprächen
berichtet wird und da das vorgespräche
sind werden wird auch alle weiteren
fragen was es auf dem brötchen käse oder
wurst gab oder wie wir strategisch
weiter vorgehen dazu jetzt weiterhin
nicht sagen jetzt erst steigen union und
spd in die gespräche ein werden jeweils
für ein jamaika oder ampel bündnis die
entscheidung fällt am 6 fdp und grüne
wollen die ampel versuchen also statt
der sondierungsgespräche ab dem siebten
oktober verhandeln spd fdp und grüne
dann zutritt die ersten kompromisse
festgehalten in einem zwölfseitigen
sondierungs papier präsentieren sie am
15 oktober
und geben sich so euphorisch wie schon
lange nicht mehr
wir sind überzeugt nach diesen
gesprächen dass es lange zeit keine
vergleichbare chance gegeben hat
gesellschaft wirtschaft und staat zu
modernisieren
der große gewinner einer solchen
koalition wird am ende nicht eine
einzelne partei sein sondern unser land
am 21.10 bei stürmischem wetter dann
offizieller start der
koalitionsverhandlungen in der hoffnung
dass es drinnen ruhiger zugeht ihre
deadline verkürzen die koalitionäre
sogar olaf scholz soll schon in der
nikolaus woche zum kanzler gewählt
werden bis zum 10 november wird dann
über themen wie digitalisierung
klimaschutz arbeit und familie
verhandelt 300 personen in 22
fachgruppen sie erarbeiten
positionspapiere als grundlage für die
schlussphase der koalitionsgespräche
denn ab dem 15 11 sind die verhandlungen
dann chefsache ministerien werden
zugeschnitten und die letzten
streitpunkte geklärt
ja und da stehen wir als heute und jetzt
würde ich gerne hören professor korte in
unsere gesprächsrunde dazu holen hallo
hallo schön dass sie bei uns sind sie
werden uns heute bei der politischen
analyse unterstützen erklärte das was
sie bis jetzt gehört haben nicole
diekmann hat ja die wesentlichen key
facts da schon zusammengetragen sind da
überraschung für sie dabei gewesen
naja die aufteilung der ministerien ist
schon überraschung denn wir wissen ja in
den letzten tagen kursierten aller
halbstunden neue ressort verteilungen
und auch namen hier ist markant eine
veränderung eingetreten die so nicht
erwartbar war es gibt eine so weniger
abgestuft zwischen spd und den anderen
parteien die fdp hat eine noch mal
weniger als die grünen insofern wird
durchaus das abbild der mandate
übertragen in diesem ressort bildung der
bundesregierung wir waren eher davon
ausgegangen dass beide gleichermaßen
bedient wird also diese kiwi koalition
die grün-gelben gespräche waren ja
vorgelagerte das finde ich neu das war
so bisher nicht erwartbar und es zeigt
sich damit auch dass der preis für ein
finanzministerium ziemlich hoch ist ganz
offensichtlich und so ausgeglichen
werden musste für die spd ist vollkommen
neu in der großen tradition von schmidt
und leber und struck wieder das
verteidigungsministerium führen zu
können so hier sind durchaus neue
akzente zu sehen die man so bisher im
vorfeld nicht ahnen konnte ich habe hier
diese diese kernbotschaften des
koalitionsvertrages vorliegen und das
fängt an mit mehr fortschritt wagen
bündnis für freiheit gerechtigkeit und
nachhaltigkeit
sagt er die reihenfolge freiheit
gerechtigkeit nachhaltigkeit fdp spd
grüne schon so ein bisschen was über das
jahr über die stimmengewichtung über das
machtverhältnis aus das ist eine ein
neues bündnis was an dass wir uns
gewöhnen müssen nicht nur das es dreier
koalition sind auf bundesebene sondern
auch insofern neu weil das ampel bisher
in dieser form ja noch nicht gab und
die besonderheit liegt darin dass wir
eine koalition eben haben an die wir uns
gewöhnen müssen weil sie nicht wider
willen gebildet worden ist sondern eine
frei ausgewählt worden ist die kroko
davor war ja fast zwangsweise
zusammengeschweißt worden damit es
überhaupt zu einer regierung kam
dass jetzt viele neue energie frei aber
es macht auch deutlich dass diese neue
junge bürgerlichkeit die sich neu
gefunden hat in der politischen mitte
auch nach neuen ausdruck natürlich sucht
und da war ein weg am meist
zurückzulegen für die fdp die ihr er in
einem mitte links bündnis für mit rechts
steht insofern war sie an den
brückenbauarbeiten wohl am interessieren
interessierten und wollte diese brücke
auch möglichst breit und lang für sich
gestaltet haben dass kann zukünftig für
sie wird sehr wichtig sein weil sie
vielleicht in diesem bündnis seine rolle
der union übernehmen kann in der
projektion also ist die
ausgangsbedingungen unterschiedlich
gewesen für alle drei und deswegen
könnte nicht ohne grund auch mit
freiheit der startpunkt in der
überschrift gesetzt worden sein wir
haben noch ein paar minuten zeit deshalb
schauen wir vielleicht noch mal kurz wie
der fahrplan jetzt für die kommenden
wochen es deshalb johanna sagt meister
noch mal für uns zusammengefasst
die ampel parteien haben ihren
ambitionierten zeit kann also
eingehalten weitergehen soll es jetzt so
an vierter und fünfter dezember stimmen
parteitage von fdp und spd über den
koalitionsvertrag ab bei den grünen
dürfen alle mitglieder abstimmen per
digitaler uhr war das ergebnis soll
innerhalb von zehn tagen kommen das
grüne licht käme dann also gerade noch
rechtzeitig dass olaf scholz und seine
minister innen in der woche vom 6
dezember auf der regierungsbank platz
nehmen können
also das wäre dieser nach wie vor sehr
sehr ambitionierte zeitplan professor
korte wie ist denn das als
politikwissenschaftler reiben sie sich
manchmal immer noch die augen wenn sie
sich überlegen was die spd da in den
letzten monaten von durch maschen gelegt
hat
ja das spricht für schnelle
lernfähigkeit und für hohe
professionalität und für allerdings für
langen atmen wenn in der
ausgangssituation hat sich offenbar die
spd am strategisch sichersten
vorbereitet langfristig scholz wurde
deshalb oft verlacht dass er daran
festgehalten hat dass die zentrale frage
bei der bundestagswahl sein wird wer
wird merkel und auch diese erbschaft hat
er sich bis in die hohe symbolik der
raute am ende eingearbeitet und
strategie fähig gemacht für merkliche
sicherheitsgefühl und er hat in der
professionelle begleitung der
parteileitungen es geschafft alles
andere ruhig zu stellen das war eine
große kraftanstrengung sofern die in
einer extrem professionellen kampagne an
den start wie bundestagswahl gegangen
und haben diese fast schon aggressive
schweigsamkeit auch beibehalten das
beeindruckende an diesem kurs zur
verhandlung ist für mich durchaus der
lerneffekt zu 2017 der ja nicht nur in
der aggressiven
verschwiegenheit liegt sondern auch
darin so ein papier zu stande zu bringen
als fundament für diese am ende der
sondierung das ist klassisch richtig gut
geworden im sinne des aufbaus dann der
beteiligung der parteien auch in
verschwiegenheit über 360 prozent aus
den ländern 40 prozent aus dem bunt und
er ist erleichtert kommt hierzu bei
diesen verhandlungen von menschen die
sich kennenlernen mussten in dieser
zusammensetzung das ist keine kanzlerin
dabei war das hat die sache sicherlich
auch erleichtert aber so ein
disziplinierter zeitplan ist interessant
wenn man jetzt in das papier ein guckt
sieht es danach aus dass man so eine
ständige begleitung als evaluation auch
ins papier aufgenommen also ich kann
viel erkennen von aguila
prozessorientierter moderner
arbeitsweise wie man auch auf die
geschäftsordnung der bundesregierung
übertragen möchte die man auch
modernisieren möchte das also viel
bewegung in den arbeitsprozessen und was
sie vor gemacht haben war gut bis zu
diesem punkt es gibt einen inhaltlichen
kritik punkt den man mit sicherheit
sieht wir haben nicht führungs
bereitschaft in der pandemie erkannt
also da sind wir als bürger schon gar
nicht da ist von staatsversagen die rede
da hat sich doch vieles weggeduckt in
dieser letzten zeit und die frage ob das
unter kroner bedingungen ein glücklicher
start
wir sehen jetzt gerade vielleicht können
wir das noch mal zeigen die bilder wie
annalena baerbock saskia esken dahinter
sich norbert walter borjans und robert
habeck sich für ein foto bereit machen
ja da steht jemand davor deshalb
christian lendner christian lindner und
volker wissing eben die köpfe die
architekten dieser neuen koalition
setzen sich für
dieses foto in szene nicole ich möchte
dich mal kurz fragen es begann ja
relativ romantisch mit diesem self von
bissing lindner habeck und baerbock und
jetzt sehen wir dieses foto diese szene
wie
war der weg doch zwischendurch mal
steinig nach außen wurde er immer sehr
demonstriert dass das alles sehr
harmonisch abläuft na ja man hat heute
schon in den sozialen netzwerken
quasi den bogen gespannt michael kellner
und lars klingbeil quasi die
generalsekretäre ihrer parteien haben
wollte auch nochmal einzige twitter das
heißt das signal dass davon ausgehen
soll ist wir sind gar gelandet wo wir
auch angefangen hatten also es ist eine
runde sache natürlich hat es
zwischendurch geschäft hat annalena
baerbock hat es dann doch irgendwann mal
freimütig rausgelassen dass es nicht
immer einfach war dass man auch mal
gerne aus dem raum wollte und laut
werden wollte aber die frage ist von wo
man kommt also dass eine ampel so
geräuschlos und so schnell überein kommt
gerade mit so unterschiedlichen
positionen in fragen wie klima zum
beispiel zwischen auf der einen seite
grünen und auf der anderen seite fdp das
hätten sich viele auch nicht träumen
lassen aber natürlich klar nochmal es
hat zwischendurch auch mal gekracht
so jetzt sehen wir noch mal das foto
weiter olaf scholz ist natürlich auch
dabei derweil noch nicht zu erkennen auf
der linken seite der grünen
bundesgeschäftsführer kellner und rechts
neben saskia esken genau hier ist
klingbeil wir gehen jetzt rein und dann
erwarten wir jetzt jeden moment dass die
pressekonferenz mit der vorstellung des
neuen koalitionsvertrag der neuen
regierung beginnen wird ich kenne die
wege nicht wie das in diesem convention
center ist sofern jetzt sind sie
reingegangen
was erwartest du jetzt für die nächsten
minuten nicole
gleich auf der bühne stehen werden sehr
großen wert darauf legen werden
geschlossenheit zu symbolisieren
professor korte hat das eben schon mal
kurz angesprochen diese ampel ist noch
nicht im amt diese arbeit hat die
regierungsgeschäfte noch nicht
übernommen hat aber schon viel kritik
einstecken müssen nämlich dafür dass sie
nicht nur über die
koalitionsverhandlungen geschwiegen hat
sondern auch nach empfinden vieler
bürgerinnen und bürger und auch
kommentatoren und kommentatoren zum
thema cola wir verbuchen einen negativ
rekord nach dem anderen seit tagen was
instanzen angeht die vierte welle ist
mit voller wucht da so schlimm wie keine
zuvor und da gab es doch immer wieder
mal den ruf nach führung nach dem signal
wir wissen wie schlimm es steht wir
stellen uns vor die kameras und
senden das signal aus dass wir um die
nöte wissen wir sehen den
handlungsbedarf und wir sehen eben auch
den bedarf danach dieses signal
auszusenden wir dürfen nicht vergessen
politik lebt auch von ganz viel symbolik
von signalen die gesendet werden das
heißt ich bin gespannt darauf ob das
gleich auch zur sprache kommen wird
neben eben der symbolik geschlossenheit
handlungsfähigkeit einigkeit und ich bin
auch gespannt ich habe ja eben schon
namen genannt die kursieren herr korte
auch wie viel man sich da gleich
entlocken lässt denn es wird ja auch
fragen geben von anwesenden
medienvertretern genau und wir sehen wie
vielleicht können wir das bild von der
pressekonferenz jetzt nochmal zeigen
da sehen wir wie die kamera männer und
frauen die fotografinnen sich vorne
versammeln alle warten eben darauf dass
die spitzen von spd grünen und fdp jetzt
hier auf das podium treten und den
koalitionsvertrag vorstellen dass kann
nicht mehr lange dauern wir haben ja
gesehen sie alle sind schon ins gebäude
ein wir werden alle ganz genau zuhören
nicole diekmann bleibt bei uns professor
porte bleibt bei uns und dann werden wir
die ganze sache danach noch analysieren
und dann kommt ja auch noch die freude
ist future klimaschutz aktivistin luisa
neubauer zu und sehen uns mit sicherheit
nicole es ist erwartbar einiges zum
klimaschutz thema sagen wird da
werden wird sie wahrscheinlich nicht
ganz zufrieden sein
immer wieder auch von freiheit ist
verfügt die kritik dass selbst die ziele
der grünen auch im wahlkampf war da
schon ein thema das das nicht dem
entspricht was man zum beispiel von
seiten frei des verführers aber auch
anderen gruppierungen da eigentlich
erwartet man hat versucht druck zu
machen und ehrgeizigere ziele in diesem
koalitionsvertrag
hinein verhandeln zu lassen also es
würde mich jetzt sehr überraschen wenn
da
hundertprozentiger applaus vonseiten
eines neubaus kommen würde ja ja es so
zu erwarten solange noch niemand ich
sehe hier an der seite den monitor und
ich sehe ganz genau wenn jemand jetzt da
raus kommt also lange das noch nicht der
fall ist können wir noch eine frage von
isabel vielleicht auf facebook
beantworten sie fragt sich welches
werden wohl die ersten themen sein
welche von der neuen regierung
angegangen werden nicole ganz klar klima
auf jeden fall das lässt sich schon raus
gesellschaft das heute schon einmal hier
erwähnt mein angemeckert es kurz papier
das sie heute bekommen haben da ist das
ist eine kurze zusammenfassung dessen
was uns jetzt gleich erwartet und auch
das koalitionsvertrag ist da ist klima
ein eigener punkt da ist wohnen an
eigener punkt ich hab's ja vorhin schon
gesagt es wird ein neu geschaffen das
ministerium geben eigens für wohnen das
wohl die spd dem vernehmen nach
übernehmen wird
corona ist ein thema in diesem papier
mehr geld für pflegekräfte ist unter
anderem eine ein ziel das man sich auf
die fahnen schreibt eine stabile rente
das war ja auch ein großes
wahlkampfthema und auch die
digitalisierung die ja wohl kein eigenes
ministerium bekommen wird aber die wir
haben ist allerspätestens
in dieser pandemie alle erkennen müssen
digitalisierung da ist noch sehr viel
luft nach oben hier in deutschland und
auch das steht in diesem papier und das
sind einige der punkte die sicherlich
gleich angesprochen werden dann könnten
wir vielleicht noch einmal eine frage an
professor korte stellen die kommt von
tobias kaiser auf youtube per karte
wieviel parteitaktik können sich die
drei koalitionsparteien innerhalb der
regierung in den nächsten vier jahren
erlauben
alle sind darauf ausgerichtet
wiedergewählt zu werden das ist
entscheidend und insofern ist es schon
bewährungsprobe die themen so anzulegen
dass man nicht nur probleme löst sondern
am ende auch wieder gewählt werden kann
das ist die ratio die hinter der politik
liegt die voraussetzung dass drei am
ende wieder bereichen um auch
mehrheitsfähig zu werden sind ziemlich
hoch die kinder das jahr aus den ländern
in dem jetzt zum beispiel die mainz ja
auch die ampel bestätigt worden ist
insofern ist die wahrscheinlichkeit
schon hoch dass es länger wird deswegen
können wir heute auch sagen wir sprechen
von einer zäsur denn das war vor 16
jahren zuletzt ob das so lange dauert
bis man natürlich aber die ausrichtung
wird vor allem daran gemessen werden ob
konkret verbesserungen unserem alltag am
ende erkennbar sind ob wir gesetze
zielsetzungen die in der in dem programm
drin sind einhalten und vor allen dingen
wie das mit uns kommuniziert wird wenn
ein großer umbruch bevorsteht der in dem
papier eine große rolle spielt dann
müssen wir mitgenommen werden alles wird
von der politischen kommunikation
abhängen der wahlkampf war zumutung frei
jetzt kommt zumutung auf uns zu und wie
wollen wir die gemeinsam durchstehen wie
solidarisch wie fair wie gerecht wie
befristet das interessiert uns und wenn
das der regierung gelingt dann ist die
parteitaktik nicht entscheidend sondern
die kommunikation mit den bürgern und
die bereitschaft dem zu folgen der
bürger ist dann hoch wenn wir erkennen
dass es keine parteitaktik ist
darauf werden wir später nach der
pressekonferenz auch noch mal eingehen
vielen dank für den moment wir sehen
jetzt im moment das in der ersten reihe
die parteispitzen schon platz genommen
haben auch die generalsekretäre von fdp
und spd wissing und klingbeil sowie der
grünen
bundesgeschäftsführer kellner und dann
kann es ja nicht mehr lange dauern ich
würde sagen wir schauen uns jetzt mal
die pressekonferenz an sie wird in jeder
jede sekunde muss es losgehen denn wenn
man auf das bild vertraut dass die
fotografinnen und fotografen dass sie
sich alle vorne vor dem podium schon
platziert haben dann ist zu erwarten
dass olaf scholz christian lindner und
annalena baerbock und robert habeck
jetzt doch demnächst
auf die bühne treten werden und den
koalitionsvertrag für die neue regierung
in aller ausführlichkeit dann
hoffentlich auch vorstellen werden wir
schon jetzt mal rein
es scheint doch noch einen tacken länger
zu dauern für 15 uhr war es eigentlich
angesetzt jetzt haben wir 15 uhr 10 dann
nutzen wir doch einfach die zeit und
stellen doch noch eine frage auf
facebook stefanie rissig presse nein
jetzt jetzt lassen sie uns auf das pk
bild noch mal schauen herr korte wir
sprechen mit beta
und wir gehen jetzt an die presse kann
verlassen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
sie sagt dass sie alle hierher gefunden
haben zur vorstellung des
koalitionsvertrages von spd und bündnis
90/die grünen und fdp kurz auch ampel
genannt den koalitionsvertrag den finden
und sie auch auf den qr codes so dass
sie ihn schnell auch hochladen können
und wir wollen jetzt ein bisschen
darüber sprechen fangen an mit olaf
scholz als kanzlerkandidaten
meine verehrten damen und herren
bevor ich zum anlass der heutigen
pressekonferenz komme möchte ich mich zu
einem sehr sehr aktuellen thema äußern
kroner ist nach wie vor nicht besiegt
leider
tag für tag ein und neue rekorde was die
zahl der infektionen angeht auch wenn
durch die impfungen viele verläufen
deutlich milder geworden sind werden in
einigen regionen auch mehr mehr
infizierte in krankenhäusern aufgenommen
die intensivstation geraten mancherorts
an belastungsgrenzen
die lage ist ernst
die künftige bundesregierung hat
gemeinsam mit den ländern vergangene
woche entschieden die schritte
veranlasst um das pandemie geschehen
einzudämmen
diese maßnahmen sind heute in kraft
entscheidendes nun eine konsequente
umsetzung der regeln zu 2g und 3g plus
im öffentlichen raum um die
infektionszahlen zu senken
nur wer geimpft oder genesen
gegebenenfalls über einen aktuellen test
abgesichert ist sollte zur veranstaltung
im restaurant und bars zutritt erhalten
so wie heute zu dieser pressekonferenz
am arbeitsplatz und im öffentlichen
verkehr gilt seit heute die dreijährige
um infektionen zu verringern
was für veranstaltungen
restaurantbesuche und bei der arbeit
gilt
sollten wir möglichst auch bei privaten
begegnungen selbst beherzigen impfen und
tagesaktuell testen um uns und unsere
lieben zu schützen
über diese beschlüsse hinaus wird die
neue bundesregierung des weiteren
veranlassen ersten
ständigen bund länder krisenstab im
bundeskanzleramt einzurichten er wird
die lage kontinuierlich gutachten und
beobachten und die umsetzung der
beschlüsse prüfen
zweitens
eine expertengruppe im kanzleramt
einzurichten die eine tägliche
beurteilung der korona lage vornimmt und
an die regierung gerichtet
darunter virologen
epidemiologen soziologen und psychologen
und weitere fachleute wir brauchen
diesen wissenschaftlichen sachverstand
um zu klugen erkenntnissen zu kommen es
geht darum die lage eng zu beobachten
die wirkung von maßnahmen zu überprüfen
und gegebenenfalls weitere schritte zu
entwickeln
drittens
die impfkampagne weiter massiv voran zu
bringen und die kapazitäten der
impfzentren noch deutlicher auszuweiten
wir wollen mit mobilen teams in den
städten und regionen unterwegs seien und
auch ärzte und apotheken stärker
einbinden auch den einsatz der
bundeswehr im dienst halte ich für
richtig wir müssen impfen und boostern
um die verbreitung des virus zu
erschweren
viertens die beschlossenen impfung zum
schutz von variablen gruppen müssen
konsequent durchgesetzt werden um zum
beispiel alten und pflegeheime besser zu
schützen
für die besonders geforderten
pflegekräfte in den krankenhäusern und
pflegeheimen werden wir eine bonus
zahlung veranlassen die ampel koalition
hat sich darauf verständigt für diesen
pflege bonus erst einmal eine milliarde
bereitzustellen
impfen ist der ausweg aus dieser
pandemie in einrichtung in den besonders
wohlhabende gruppen betreut werden
sollten wir die impfung verpflichtend
machen eine ausweitung dieser regelung
bleibt zu prüfen
siebter die mpk beschlüsse so
rechtzeitig zu überprüfen dass wir
gegebenenfalls weitere maßnahmen beim
nächsten treffen der ministerpräsident
und ministerpräsidenten der länder mit
der bundesregierung beschließen können
meine damen und herren ich
weiß wir hatten alle die hoffnung dass
dieser winter kein corona winter werden
musste doch trotz impfung sind wir noch
nicht durch wir müssen uns abermals
zusammen nehmen die hygieneregeln
beachten abstand halten und die masten
pflicht beherzigen um einigermaßen heil
durchzukommen
gemeinsam haben wir es in der hand diese
schlimme vierte welle zu brechen die
neue bundesregierung wird alles
erforderliche tun um unser land gut
durch diese zeit zu bringen
und damit komme ich zum eigentlichen
anlass für unsere pressekonferenz zum
abschluss der koalitionsberatungen
meine wichtigste botschaft dazu lautet
die ampel steht
spd grüne und fdp haben sich in den
verhandlungen auf einen gemeinsamen
koalitionsvertrag verständigt und damit
auf ein neues regierungsbündnis
diesen vertrag legen wir nun unseren
parteien zur abstimmung vor und wir
werben intensiv dafür dass alle drei
parteien diesen vertrag in den nächsten
zehn tagen zustimmen werden
unser ziel ist das erste bündnis von rot
grün und gelb auf bundesebene zu führen
eine koalition auf augenhöhe mit drei
partnern die ihre stärken einbringen zum
wohle unseres landes
und der glaube an den fortschritt und
daran dass politik etwas gutes bewirken
kann uns eint der wille das land besser
zu machen es voran zu bringen und es
beisammen zu halten
es geht uns nicht um eine politik des
kleinsten gemeinsamen nenners sondern um
eine politik der großen wirkung
wir wollen uns etwas zutrauen beim
klimaschutz beim umbau unserer industrie
bei der modernisierung des landes bei
der stärkung des gesellschaftlichen
zusammenhalts
wir wollen mehr fortschritt tragen
mit ehrgeiz und beharrlichkeit werden
wir unser land zum vorreiter beim
klimaschutz machen mit dem konsequenten
und zügigen ausbau der erneuerbaren
energien mit einer beschleunigung des
planungsrechts die industrie
unterstützen wir beim umstieg auf
klimaneutrale produktion
spitzentechnologie made in germany wird
es auch in zukunft geben
im wahlkampf habe ich viel über respekt
gesprochen ein respekt der eine menge
mit anerkennung zu tun hat aber dort
nicht verraten ich bin froh dass wir
miteinander vereinbart haben den
mindestlohn in einem schritt auf 12 euro
zu erhöhen wie ich es angekündigt habe
das bedeutet eine gehaltserhöhung für
zehn millionen bürgerinnen und bürger
wir führen die kindergrundsicherung ein
die armut verhindern und bessere chancen
für kinder und jugendliche schaffen wird
zugleich halten wir die rente wie
versprochen stabil und entwickeln sie
fort
und wir haben miteinander vereinbart im
kampf gegen hohe mieten den wohnungsbau
voran zu treiben
400.000 neue wohnungen pro jahr davon
100.000 öffentlich gefördert werden wir
bauen
die modernisierung unseres landes gibt
es nicht zum nulltarif
wir werden massiv investieren um
deutschland in der weltspitze zu halten
diese investitionen haben wir
miteinander vereinbart und dabei werden
wir die schuldenbremse einhalten dem
grundgesetz garantiert ist
ein souveränes europa ist der schlüssel
und für unsere außenpolitik als
wirtschaftlich starkes und
bevölkerungsreichen land im herzen
europas ist es unsere aufgabe diese
souveräne europa zu ermöglichen zu
fördern und voranzubringen
die freundschaft zu frankreich
die partnerschaft mit den vereinigten
staaten und der einsatz für frieden und
wohlstand in der welt sind die säulen
auf denen unsere außenpolitik fust und
nun lassen sie mich noch ein paar sätze
sagen zu den verhandlungen der
vergangenen wochen die sie ja eigentlich
von ferne verfolgen konnten wofür ich
mich nicht entschuldigen möchte
in diesen tagen und wochen haben wir eng
intensiv und mitunter leidenschaftlich
vor allem aber vertrauensvoll
miteinander verhandelt alle drei
parteien seien es die grünen angeführt
von annalena baerbock und robert habeck
die liberalen von christian lindner oder
die spd mit saskia esken und norbert
walter borjans alle haben die gespräche
mit großem engagement geführt
konstruktiv und immer lösungsorientiert
angetrieben vom willen das land gut zu
regieren und es voran zu bringen
das hat mir gut gefallen und in mir das
gefühl verstärkt dass hier tatsächlich
etwas
zusammengewachsen ist in der koalition
die erste verkehrsampel ist im jahre
1924 in berlin errichtet worden am
potsdamer platz
damals zunächst noch eine ungewöhnliche
technik kann das funktionieren
haben die leute skeptisch gefragt
heute ist die ampel nicht mehr
wegzudenken wenn es darum geht die dinge
klar zu regeln und für die richtige
orientierung zu sorgen und dafür dass
alle zügig und sicher vorankommen
mein anspruch als bundeskanzler ist es
dass dieses ampelbündnis eine ähnlich
wegweisende rolle für deutschland
spielen wird schön dann
[Applaus]
und ich warte noch auf wertlos und dann
kann man verspätet also sehr geehrte
damen und herren auch von unserer von
meiner seite guten tag und herzlich
willkommen während wir verhandelt haben
olaf scholz hat eben den stil der
verhandlungen ein bisschen beschrieben
haben sich einige krisen dramatisch
zugespitzt und entwickelt die situation
an den außengrenzen in belarus aber eben
vor allem die korona pandemie und
während wir um worte und interpretation
gerungen haben es sorge und angst in
deutschland umgegangen menschen stehen
den schlangen warten auf die booster
impfung impfung und gehen dann
unverrichteter dinge wieder weg wir
übernehmen oder werden die regierung in
einer zeit der krise übernehmen und wir
sind uns und ich bin urlaub stolz
dankbar dass er das eben noch einmal so
ausgeführt hat klar darüber dass wir
alles notwendige tun werden um die
vierte welle zu brechen und die krone
pandemie beherrschbaren zu halten
in einer zeit wo so viel sorge angst und
verunsicherung da ist es ist wichtig
dass wenigstens ab und zu ein zeichen
ein dokument in diesem fall des mutes
und der zuversicht gegeben wird und ein
solches liegen wir ihnen hiermit heute
vor
das leid wird dieser regierung ist eine
handelnde gesellschaft investieren der
staat und ein deutschland das
schlichtweg funktioniert
die viertgrößte volkswirtschaft der welt
die industrie stärkste nation europas
bekommt eine neue regierung eine
regierung die es in der konstellation
nicht gab die sich gefunden hat und
weiter finden wird
ein land in einer zeit der krise zu
modernisieren bedeutet eine große
anstrengung und eine große
entschlossenheit ist notwendig
grundlage für diese anstrengung und
entschlossenheit die haben wir jetzt
geschaffen und im kern dieser neuen
geschichte die wir zusammen schreiben
können ist die vereinbarkeit von
wohlstand und klimaschutz wie ein roter
faden zieht sich der gedanke durch das
gegensätze durch eine neue politik sich
ergänzen können überwunden werden können
am massivsten wahrscheinlich zu
beobachten bei dem verhältnis zwischen
wohlstand und wachstum und dem schutz
des klimas und der natürlichen
ressourcen wir haben darüber gestritten
ob wir die klimaschutzziele in
deutschland die der groko dass bis 2030
die co2 emissionen um 65 prozent gesenkt
werden sollen noch anheben können und
haben uns dagegen entschieden dass in
den koalitionsvertrag reinzuschreiben
wir haben stattdessen einen anderen weg
gewählt nicht also immer größere ziele
zu beschreiben und zu ernennen aber in
der wirklichkeit immer hinter den
gesteckten zielen zurück zu bleiben
sondern konkrete maßnahmen zu
identifizieren wie wir die ziele
erreichen können solche maßnahmen sind
ausbau der erneuerbaren energien auf 80%
maßnahmen dass der co2 preis der
zertifikate nicht unter 60 euro fällt
was bedeutet dass der kohleausstieg
vorgezogen werden wird dass die
erneuerbaren energien nicht mehr ein
zusatz sind sondern im öffentlichen
interesse stehen dass sie die
versorgungssicherheit zu tragen haben
und nun haben wir nachgerechnet und
sehen dass wir mit all den maßnahmen die
wir beschlossen haben über die 65
prozent hinaus gegangen sind wir sind
auf 1,5 grad fahrt mit diesem
koalitionsvertrag der geist der dahinter
steht ist in der wirklichkeit zu agieren
in diesem fall natürlich erst einmal
einen leitfaden zu schreiben in der
wirklichkeit zu agieren und dann in der
gegenwart das bestmögliche zu tun auch
die zweite große ökologische krise
unserer zeit es adressiert wir haben das
artensterben und das höfesterben ist
schreit nach einem neuen denken in einer
landwirtschaftspolitik ihn nicht mehr
wachse oder weiche kennt und das finden
wir in diesem koalitionsvertrag
die roadmap genau da hin zu kommen mehr
ökolandbau reduktion von pestiziden
förderung der bäuerlichen betriebe beim
umbau der tierhaltung und so versöhnen
wir den gegensatz von schützen und
nutzen durch eine neue politik sehr
geehrte damen und herren die bei
christian olaf anna-lena
saskia und norbert es war manchmal ganz
schön anstrengend
wir haben uns ganz schön viel zugemutet
aber wir werden eine regierung sein die
auch anderen menschen etwas zumutet also
müssen wir uns auch etwas zumuten die
entscheidenden momente bei diesen
verhandlungen war machen immer dann wenn
man voneinander gelernt hat nachdem man
sich seine programmpunkte vorgetragen
hat und gesagt hat wir konnten nur so
hoch sein dass nicht zu verstehen dass
hp jetzt schon der 20 jahren gehört hört
endlich mal zu und die lautstärke wurde
immer größer gab es manchmal momente wo
es gekippt ist und man den hintergrund
der argumentation verstanden hat und
dann wurden neue lösungen möglich und so
lösen sich vielleicht auch in dieser
ampel ein was wir für die gesellschaft
beschreiben gegensätze können überwunden
werden durch eine lernende politik ein
lernendes deutschland eine lernende
politik das ist das versprechen dass wir
uns geben
[Applaus]
verehrte damen meine herren wir
übernehmen verantwortung für ein land
das in einer tiefen und noch nicht
überwundenen gesundheitskrise steckt wir
appellieren an alle menschen
sich impfen zu lassen oder sich um eine
auffrischung der impfung zu bemühen
ich bitte sie schränken sie in diesem
herbst und winter auch ihre persönlichen
kontakte
eingrenzen sie sie auf das was nötig ist
damit wir alle in diesen schwierigen
zeiten
die freiheit der gesellschaft bewahren
und die gesundheit von uns allen
schützen können
das staatliche krisenmanagement der
künftigen bundesregierung
wird sich verändern es wird optimiert
aber es wird nicht weniger konsequent
sein um schaden von diesem land
abzuwenden
die gesundheitskrise ist eine aktuelle
herausforderung für die künftige
bundesregierung
aber wir haben auch bestehende
herausforderungen
denen wir uns widmen müssen
dekarbonisierung unseres lebens
digitalisierung des lebens die frage der
alterung der gesellschaft
das sind große aufgaben vor denen wir
gemeinsam stehen
wir spüren dass es in unserem land auch
den willen und den wunsch zur und nach
veränderung gibt
diese drei parteien haben in den
wahlkämpfen der vergangenen jahre ihre
unterschiedlichkeit nicht verborgen wenn
ich das einmal so sagen darf aber wir
haben uns in einem punkt
eine gemeinsamkeit erhalten nämlich den
status quo überwinden zu wollen wir
haben gemeinsam einen auftrag dieses
land zu modernisieren
insbesondere auch die junge generation
hat uns beauftragt diesen status quo der
vergangenen jahre zu überwinden
wir haben jetzt intensiv miteinander
gesprochen
die gespräche waren sehr diskret
außergewöhnlich diskret für die
politische kultur unseres landes der
letzten jahre ich versichere ihnen die
gespräche waren genau so kontrovers wie
sie diskret war
um einzelne sätze haben wir teilweise
stunden gerungen
sozialdemokraten und grüne können jetzt
stolz sein auf das was sie in diesem
koalitionsvertrag hineinverhandelt haben
das waren starke verhandler guten
argumenten ich glaube dass unsere
zukünftigen partner in der
ampelkoalition
in ihren parteien mit besten argumenten
für dieses verhandlungsergebnis werben
können für die fdp will ich sagen dass
wir auch unsere beiträge zum gelingen
leisten werden und dass die gremien der
fdp die heute über den koalitionsvertrag
beraten haben mit dem ergebnis ebenfalls
zufrieden sind was jetzt gebildet wird
ist eine regierung der mitte
die das land nach vorn führt
wir bilden eine koalition in der sich
die drei ports norden nicht begrenzen
durch das was unvereinbar in den
programmen war sondern wir erweitern und
weil jede politische kraft natürlich
auch blinde flecken hat wir sind also
keine koalition des ausschließen sondern
der
komplementären politik
erreicht worden ist erstens dass
deutschland weiter anwalts solider
finanzen bleibt gerade angesichts der
sorgen vieler menschen um geld irrtum
ist dies wichtig es gelegt die breite
mitte des landes durch unterschiedliche
maßnahmen zu entlasten ohne dass es zu
belastungen an anderer stelle kommt
zweitens es gibt in unserem land so
viele private initiative privates know
how und privates kapital
das wir nun endlich entfesseln wollen um
unseren weg fortzusetzen in einer
dekarbonisierung digitalisierte
technologie nation die in der lage ist
wohlstand und wachstum für mehr menschen
zu organisieren
drittens wir werden diesen staat
digitalisieren
viertens wir bemühen uns in bester
anknüpfung übrigens an die sozial
liberale koalition der siebziger jahre
um die verbesserung der bildung und der
sozialen aufstiegs chance in unserem
land eines der versprechen der sozialen
marktwirtschaft was dringend erneuert
werden muss fünftens wir stehen für eine
gesellschaftspolitische liberalisierung
vielfalt individualität
das verbindet uns
diese fünf punkte beschreiben
trendwenden wo wir neues wagen einen
aufbruch organisieren wollen
aber es gibt auch kontinuität dinge die
sich nicht verändern die uns gemeinsam
wichtig sind
die bundesrepublik deutschland wird auch
mit einer ampelkoalition
ein verlässlicher partner bleiben im
westlichen bündnis
in der europäischen union
und in der gemeinschaft demokratische
rechtsstaaten auf der welt
wir haben außerordentlich ambitionierte
vorhaben wenn sie den koalitionsvertrag
im einzelnen auswerten werden sie das
lesen wir haben außerordentlich
ambitionierte vorhaben und deshalb
spüren wir demut
angesichts der dimension dessen was wir
uns vorgenommen haben
diese demut ist ratsam angesichts der
herausforderungen wir werden diese
vorhaben auch nicht alleine umsetzen
können wir sind angewiesen auf die
unterstützung aus der gesellschaft aus
der wirtschaft und wir werden auch die
unterstützung derjenigen brauchen die
diese koalition nicht gewählt haben und
die sich zukünftig in der
oppositionsrolle wiederfinden
wir haben während der verhandlungen olaf
scholz neu kennengelernt
natürlich kannten wir ihn aus seinen
früheren staatsämtern
aus dem politischen meinungsstreit im
parlament zumal
wir haben ihnen aber neu kennengelernt
während der verhandlungen wir haben ihn
erlebt als eine starke
führungspersönlichkeit
die über die erfahrung und
professionalität
verfügt dieses land in eine gute zukunft
zu leiten vor allen dingen aber haben
wir seine innere haltung erlebt um es
mit egon bahr zu sagen oder scholz
verfügt über ein inneres geländer
um aus einer klaren werthaltung heraus
dieses land nach vorne zu führen und
weit mehr menschen zu repräsentieren als
nur sozialdemokratisch grün oder liberal
gewählt haben und deshalb wird olaf
scholz ein starker bundeskanzler der
bundesrepublik deutschland sein
[Applaus]
meine sehr verehrten damen und herren
ist es so ok bitte bitte
meine sehr verehrten damen und herren in
nicht einfachen zeiten schaffen wir ein
bündnis das anspruchsvoll ist dass sich
aber nicht versteckt vor den großen
herausforderungen vor den krisen sondern
die chancen in dieser zeit sieht und
deswegen haben wir in den letzten wochen
gemeinsam gerungen danke für das
verständnis
dass wir das wirklich intensiv gemacht
haben weil wir einen neuen aufbruch
vorschob fortschritt schaffen wollen und
uns in dieser zeit nicht leisten können
hinter mauern zu verstecken und den
kleinsten gemeinsamen nenner zu suchen
sondern wirklich in den entscheidenden
land bereichen dieses landes ein
paradigmenwechsel einzuleiten den es
braucht für die modernisierung unseres
landes für die modernisierung unseres
staates und vor allen dingen für den
zusammenhalt in unserer gesellschaft
und wir haben für die größte
herausforderung unserer zeit die
klimakrise mit diesem gemeinsamen
koalitionsentwurf den wir jetzt unseren
parteien vorlegen
den weg dafür bereitet dass wir als eine
der größten industrienationen der welt
klimaneutral werden können und zwar
klimaneutral im herzen europas gemeinsam
mit unseren europäischen
nachbarn und freunden und so wie wir vor
20 jahren mit erneuerbaren energien
eine neue technologie in die welt
gebracht haben die nicht nur eine
technologie war sondern die die
energiepolitik aber auch die
internationale zusammenarbeit verändert
hat ist das jetzt ein paradigmenwechsel
wo wir die wirtschaft auf
klimaneutralität stellen können und das
gemeinsam als beitrag für mehr
sicherheit in der welt auf den weg
singen können und deswegen haben ja
einen
koalitionsentwurf geschaffen wo sich
diese frage der klimaneutralität durch
alle bereiche des koalitionsvertrages
durchzieht von der umwelt politik über
die landwirtschaft die verkehrspolitik
die industrie und wirtschaftspolitik
aber eben auch die internationale
zusammenarbeit und außen und
sicherheitspolitik und das bedeutet auch
dass die frage einer gemeinsamen
klimapolitik eine europäische antwort
bedarf und vor allen dingen einer
aktiven energie und außenpolitik bedarf
um diese krise große menschheitsaufgabe
gemeinsam anzugehen und wir erleben
gerade dass wir diese gemeinsame aufgabe
in einer zeit angehen wo die krisen auch
um uns herum im direkten umfeld mitten
in europa schwerer werden wo die
herausforderung schwerer werden werden
wir die situation in belarus sehen wenn
wir die situation an den außengrenzen
europas sehen daher haben wir uns
gemeinsam darauf verständigt wieder zu
einer aktiven europäischen
außenpolitik
zurückzukommen die auf die stärke der
diplomatie und des dialoges setzt und
auf eine werte- und menschenrechts
geleitete gemeinsame diplomatie
ein anderer großer paradigmenwechsel in
diesem papier ist dass wir
nicht immer nur alles aus der sichtweise
von erwachsenen sehen sondern dass wir
eine regierung bilden für die vielfalt
unserer gesellschaft eine regierung
unter samt viele familien in unserem
land in dieser corona pandemie immer
wieder gespürt die auch die kleinsten
und jüngsten die kinder und die
jugendlichen die jungen menschen in
unserem land sieht und versteht dass
kinder keine kleinen erwachsenen sind
sondern kinder eigene rechte haben und
entsprechend sind vier projekte
verankert wie eine kindergrundsicherung
die ein wirkliches umdenken nicht nur
der sozialpolitik bedeutet in dem man
kinder aus dem harz 4 system herausholte
eigentlich kindern ihr ein gehört haben
sondern indem man kinder und jugendliche
eine andere bedeutung in dieser
zukünftigen bundesregierung gibt und das
als beitrag zu einer
generationenübergreifenden
politik die nicht jede einzelne gruppe
für sich sieht sondern die vielfalt in
der gesellschaft als stärker begreift
und auch für die vielfalt dieser
gesellschaft gemeinsam politik macht und
da ist die konstellation die ja einige
von uns gerade schon angesprochen haben
dass wir auch nicht eine homogene gruppe
sind wo immer alle schon
wissen dass sie 100 prozent recht haben
sich zu 100 prozent durchsetzen nein
sondern in einer dreier konstellation
kann sich niemand zu 100 prozent
durchsetzen was aber eine möglichkeit
gibt auch mal den standpunkt zu wechseln
und zu verstehen dass wenn christian
lindner eine 6 auf der seite sieht und
sich einen neuen sehen dass wir
vielleicht beide recht haben können und
wir nur bereit sein müssen mal die
sichtweise des anderen hinzunehmen und
in einer zeit wo soviel auch
gegeneinander und spaltung in der
gesellschaft vorhanden ist eine
regierung zu bilden
die bereit ist im blickwinkel zu
wechseln und gemeinsam lösungen und
antworten zu finden bedeutet für uns
auch eine modernisierung des
gesellschaftlichen vertrages eine
modernisierung des
staatsbürgerschaftsrechts eine
modernisierung des familienrechts die
auf der höhe des einundzwanzigsten
jahrhundert ist und dafür schaffen wir
hier gemeinsam die grundlage und auch
von meiner seite herzlichen dank mischen
und diejenigen die ich auf der bühne
stehen sondern sie haben sich ja gefragt
warum wir in messehallen unter anderem
getagt haben weil wir eben die vielfalt
auch unserer parteien mit eingebracht
haben und mit hunderten von der
verhandlerin und verhandlern in
arbeitsgruppen gesprochen haben und auch
und denjenigen an dieser stelle
herzlichen dank genauso an diejenigen
menschen die sich in dieser schwierigen
zeit an uns gewandt haben und deutlich
gemacht haben unsere erfahrungen in den
letzten anderthalb jahren corona
pandemie die müssen sich in einer neuen
regierung widerspiegeln das hat olaf
scholz eingangs gesagt auch dass es die
erste aufgabe dieser neuen ampel
konstellation
[Applaus]
meine damen und herren ich bin mir sehr
gewiss wir haben mit diesem
koalitionsvertrag etwas auf die beine
gestellt das diesem land gut tun wird
wir haben in vielen langen gesprächen
das ist hier heute schon zum ausdruck
gekommen zum teil stundenlang über
einzelne sätze gerungen worden ist eines
gemeinsam gehabt als
ausgangsvoraussetzungen und das war eine
gemeinsame fortschritts erzählung das
heißt wir müssen in diesem land
schneller werden wir müssen dinge
anpacken wir brauchen einen aufbruch und
zwar nicht nur ökonomisch und ökologisch
wir brauchen ihn auch
gesellschaftspolitisch und diese
gemeinsame grundhaltung hat uns in
diesen gesprächen getragen man weiß
jeder so sind drei parteien die mit
durchaus unterschiedlichen blickwinkeln
auf diese gemeinsame thematik gucken und
wir wollten auch nicht fusionieren wir
wollen koalieren und deswegen war klar
dass man das gleiche große ziel mit
unterschiedlichen maßnahmen mit
unterschiedlichen instrumenten angeben
will und ich kann mich christian lindner
anschließend das haben wir nicht gemacht
indem wir uns mit unseren
unterschiedlichen instrumenten
gegenseitig blockiert haben sondern dass
wir uns gegenseitig bereichert haben
durch diesen blickwinkel um eben etwas
zustande zu bringen das am ende allen
menschen in diesem land und nicht nur
unterschiedlichen partei anhängerschaft
nutzen soll ich glaube wenn man es jetzt
mal übersetzt was haben wir da gemacht
dann muss man sagen oder darf man sagen
es geht vor allem darum zu investieren
privat aber auch öffentlich in netze in
transformation in
innovative projekte die uns voran
bringen digitalisierung und das ganze
eben immer in dem blick halten dass wir
es nicht nur mit der zukunftssicherung
zu tun haben sondern dass auch die
gegenwart der menschen betroffen ist als
die menschen mit kommen wollen bei dem
was sich ändern muss von dem wir alle
wissen dass sie sich aus ändern wird und
deswegen glaube ich auch wenn es dann
andere dinge gibt wo instrumente
die für uns eine größere rolle gespielt
haben so nicht am ende durch gekommen
sind ich sag mal eine stärkere belastung
ganz große einkommen und große vermögen
dann ist trotzdem gelungen dass wir viel
für kleine und mittlere einkommen haben
erreichen können gemeinsam erreichen
können ich nenne mindestlohn ich nenne
stabile renten ich nenne bezahlbares
wohnen und dass wir auf der anderen
seite auch klar gesagt haben das
gerechtigkeitsgefühl der menschen nicht
einseitig belastet zu werden hängt auch
sehr damit zusammen wie viel wir dagegen
unternehmen das sich andere vollkommen
aus der verantwortung stehlen wollen es
recht wenn es um steuerbetrug geht aber
eben auch wenn es um trickreiche
gestaltungen von steuern geht wir haben
über die mindeststeuer gesprochen wir
haben von der klaren einstellung zur
bekämpfung der geldwäsche gesprochen wir
haben und nicht nur gesprochen sondern
wir haben klare vereinbarungen dazu
getroffen welche institutionen wir
stärken müssen wir haben klar gesagt die
investitionen die wir brauchen kosten
geld dieses geld muss zur verfügung
stehen in dem wir die schuldenbremse
nutzen mit den möglichkeiten die sie
bietet indem wir andere institutionen
wie die kreditanstalt für wiederaufbau
oder förderbanken der länder und andere
nutzen um die investitionen möglich zu
machen und ich glaube wenn man sich das
gesamtpaket anguckt dann kann man sagen
dass dieser gemeinschaftliche blick auf
gegenwart und zukunft auf klimaschutz
soziale verantwortung förderung der lust
auf innovation in diesem paket enorm
drin steckt und dass das echt diese
gemeinsame leistung ist durch das
austauschen auch unterschiedlicher
positionen das ausfechten
unterschiedlicher position und wenn ich
noch einmal auf die gegenwart nur zu
sprechen komme dann sind wir nun mal mit
diesen diskussionen mitten in einer
gesundheitskrise die wir lösen müssen
und deswegen möchte ich an dieser stelle
noch mal neben all denen die im
hintergrund und am verhandlungstisch
mitgeholfen haben zwar
ministerpräsidentinnen danken dir vorne
sitzen malu dreyer und manuela schwesig
die
ich finde in ganz wichtigen impuls
gegeben haben wie man runter kommt von
diesem was machen wir bei krone auf
zuruf sondern wie kommt man systematisch
dahin dass man wissenschaftliche
erkenntnisse und politisches handeln in
übereinstimmung bringt und dafür waren
wir alle gemeinsam das darf ich glaube
ich sagen den beiden sehr dankbar
gestern abend dass wir auf diesem weg
eben auch zusammen ein stück
weiterkommen das hat wollen die
bürgerinnen und bürger dieses landes und
ich glaube da zeigt sich auch direkt
schon im vorfeld welchen geist diese
koalition prägt welcher geist die
koalition trägt und noch eine bemerkung
nutzung schluss machen für mich ist das
ein schlusspunkt ich habe ihnen dankbar
dafür dass ich mitwirken konnte das wir
auch als spd in diese rolle kommen
konnten eine regierung zu bilden an
diesen regierungsgesprächen teilzunehmen
ich bin dankbar dafür wie wir zusammen
gefunden haben zu etwas was jetzt für
mich ein schlusspunkt aber für diese
regierung für das land ein neuer anfang
ist und deswegen bin ich sehr froh
darüber diese zwei jahre habe einsetzen
zu können und werde mich jetzt auf die
position beziehen dass ich sage jetzt
kamen dann mit anderen gucken was draus
wird die guter grundstein dafür ist
gelegt und ich freue mich sehr darüber
dass das so gelungen ist vielen dank
[Applaus]
ja meine sehr verehrten damen und herren
unser zukünftiger bundeskanzler oder
schulz lassen sie mich diese worte noch
mal genießen oder schuld also hat ein
anderer stelle mal gesagt hier ist etwas
zusammengewachsen in den letzten wochen
was zusammen passt und ich finde das ist
eine ganz kluge formulierung denn das
ist das was wir erlebt haben in den
letzten tagen und wochen wir haben sehr
sehr intensiv das ist schon gesagt
worden und sehr vertrauensvoll und
vertraulich zu manchem ärger miteinander
verhandelt so manches dazu gelernt nicht
nur über die beiden partner über die fdp
und über die über bündnis 90 die grünen
sondern auch über uns selbst wenn du uns
ja auch mit unseren eigenen positionen
auseinander setzen müssten um eben auch
wege zueinander zu finden und das ist
schon eine ganz besondere leistung wir
haben ein geschmiedet um gemeinsam
fortschritt zu wagen wir haben aber auch
verantwortung übernommen und werden das
auch weiterhin tun in der die korona
pandemie manche haben ist schon gesagt
das land natürlich auch die menschen
stark belastet ihr vizekanzler die ampel
fraktionen ebenso wie die parteispitzen
waren und sind bereit alles nötige zu
tun um die gesundheit der bürgerinnen
und bürger zu schützen die bewältigung
dieser pandemie in angriff zu nehmen
weiterhin was wir uns für die zukunft
vorgenommen haben braucht viel mut wir
wollen den wandel in dem unser land in
dem unsere weltsicht befindet aktiv
gestalten die dekarbonisierung ist
angesprochen worden die digitalisierung
ist angesprochen worden auch die
demografie natürlich eine wichtige
herausforderung aber eben auch die
wachsende anerkennung von vielfalt als
chance für den zusammenhalt in dieser
gesellschaft dieser wandel braucht nicht
nur eine mutige regierung wir alle
müssen mutig sein neues zu wagen und
dafür brauchen wir freiheit aber auch
sicherheit und zusammenhalt und daran
werden wir gemeinsam arbeiten
wir verstehen uns bei all dem als
partner in europa und in einer welt die
vieles nur gemeinsam kann das gilt für
die pandemie und andere krisen das gilt
aber auch für die wandel
ereignisse über die ich gesprochen habe
wir sind drei partner auch dass es schon
gesagt worden mit sehr unterschiedlichen
traditionen und auch mit
unterschiedlichen grundhaltung und alle
drei hatten wir einen weg zu gehen um
zusammenzufinden
wir begründen finde ich mit diesen neuen
bündnis auch eine neue form der
zusammenarbeit die neugierde und die
offenheit die wir aufgebracht haben für
die sichtweisen die argumente und die
hagen herangehensweisen jeweils der
anderen das hat uns auch viele neue
perspektiven eröffnet ich finde das ist
eine chance auch für die politik
politische kultur in deutschland
das handelsblatt hat heute morgen haben
ein hesse zitiert und spricht von
gegnern die einander brauchen weil ohne
wind keine mühlen laufen das ist ein
schönes zitat und nicht als käuferin
möchte noch eins dazu führen fügen
nämlich dass aus dem stufen gedicht
allem anfang und an jedem anfang wohnt
ein zauber inne das ist tatsächlich auch
was was ich heute empfinde das muss ich
ganz ehrlich so sagen wir sind überzeugt
dieser anfang ist uns gelungen dieses
bündnis steht für zukunft es ist für die
zukunft gemacht was wir uns vorgenommen
haben weist über die legislatur hinaus
und dafür legen wir heute den grundstein
für ein bündnis für ein
regierungsbündnis unter der führung von
bundeskanzler olaf schulz
[Applaus]
dankeschön wir kommen zu ihren fragen
sie hatten in den letzten wochen recht
sicher weise viele fragen heute gibt es
die antworten ich bitte vorab um
verzeihung ich kenne sie nicht alle und
ich erkenne schon gar nicht alle mit
ihren masken deswegen wäre generell die
bitte einfach einmal namen und medium
sagen und ich versuche mich bemerkbar zu
machen genauso wie sie sich versuchen
bemerkbar zu machen um an die sein
mikrofon zu kommen die erste frage geht
an georg ismar vom tagesspiegel und
danach die kollegin zwei reihen dahinter
und dann brauche ich mich jetzt ja nicht
noch mal extra vorstellen vielen dank
ich hätte eine frage an herrn scholz sie
haben eingangs sich zur krone lage
geäußert jetzt haben wir durch die heute
in kraft getretenen massnahmen die
sonder lage das wenn zum beispiel am 15
dezember in sachsen oder bayern lockdown
maßnahmen auslaufen dort bars clubs
gastronomie alles wieder öffnen muss ist
das wirklich verantwortbar und war es
nicht ein schwerer fehler dieses gesetz
jetzt so zu ändern hätte man es nicht
einfach weiterlaufen lassen sollen heute
treten sehr strenge regeln in kraft die
gesetzgeberische möglich gemacht worden
sind viele davon gehen weit über das
hinaus was wir bisher in deutschland
hatten für nur erinnern an die
möglichkeiten die sich mit 3g am
arbeitsplatz verbinden 3g im
öffentlichen verkehr zwei änderungen die
bisher in deutschland gar nicht möglich
gewesen sind trotzdem sind sie notwendig
weil sie den ernst der lage angemessen
sind das gilt auch für maßnahmen die zbm
zusammen mit kontakt beschränkung
vielleicht für erforderlich gehalten
werden müssen den einzelnen bereichen
auch das ist mit vorbereitet dass wir
das jetzt machen können und jetzt geht
es um eine klare entschiedene politik
die dafür sorgt dass der tagtäglich die
lage beobachten das ist der grund warum
wir vorschlagen dass es einen krisenstab
gibt er auch jetzt schon schnell
eingerichtet wird gerne auch bevor die
neue regierung ins amt gekommen ist
darum werden wir uns gemeinsam bemühen
dass das möglich ist so dass ein guter
übergang stattfinden kann und
gleichzeitig eine tägliche präsente
bekämpfung dieser corona
gesundheitskrise stattfinden kann es
gilt auch für den wissenschaftliche
begleitung die wir uns anders wünschen
als das bisher der fall ist wir wollen
nämlich präzise aus diskutierte
vorschläge haben und wir wollen ganz
konkret wissen wie entwickelt sich die
lage in den einzelnen bereichen werden
auch alle maßnahmen und alle neuen
möglichen maßnahmen umgesetzt also hier
ist klares geordnetes handeln
erforderlich dass man nichts vor sich
herschiebt sondern dass jeweils die
notwendigen entscheidungen getroffen
werden und das ist der feste wille der
kommenden regierung
spiekermann zdf hauptstadtstudio ich
würde ganz gerne bei einer personalie
noch mal nachhaken wohlmöglich die
wichtigste personalie wer
gesundheitsminister beziehungsweise
gesundheitsministerin wird
die sozialdemokratische partei wird ihre
entscheidung gut vorbereitet ich werde
entsprechende vorschläge machen das
werden wir tun
nachdem die beratungen über die bildung
des koalitionsvertrages und die
unterstützung des koalitionsvertrages in
der spd abgeschlossen sind und wir
nutzen die zeit wir haben uns jetzt
darauf konzentriert die koalition
zustande zu bringen die nächsten tage
werde ich mich sehr intensiv an die
arbeit machen eine hervorragende
besetzung der sozialdemokratischen
ressorts zustande zu bringen das gleiche
wird in den beiden anderen parteien
geschehen und der sie werden dann eine
gute lösung sei
eine frage der ferne
herr scholz hob scharf von der
tageszeitung telegraph aus amsterdam
sie präsentieren heute ein
koalitionsvertrag soll die neue
regierung anführen das passiert in einem
berliner hafen über den
g20-gipfel hatten sie gesagt das wird
nur ein hafengeburtstag das haben wir
dann gesehen dass zehntausende bürger
dort alleine gelassen wurden aus dort
geplündert wurde stundenlang und sie
reden viel über respekt auch über
gerechtigkeit
und meine frage ist wo ist dieser
respekt wenn sie die unwahrheit gesagt
haben und bezüglich treffen mit der
warburg-bank also wie oft sie dort
zusammen waren und in dieser comex
affäre ist der start der deutsche staat
betrogen und meine frage ist warum haben
sie diese bank 47 millionen euro steuer
nach haus geschenkt wobei deutsche
richter diese
personen gebrandmarkt haben aus
organisierte kriminelle
dankeschön dank für ihre frage wir haben
uns den bei der bildung dieser regierung
darauf verständigt alles zu tun damit
die innere sicherheit in deutschland
gewährleistet ist die polizei bekommt
all die notwendige unterstützung die sie
braucht damit sie alles dafür tun kann
dass kriminalität in deutschland keine
chance hat wir haben dazu sehr präzise
vorschläge gemacht auch in
gesetzgeberischen rahmen und das wird
die arbeit dieser koalition bestimmen
nein eine frage pro person wir haben
eine frage von herrn röder links
und als nächstes die kollegin in der
ersten journalisten reihe
fielen moritz mittel für die alte herr
scholz gab er gestern ein treffen im
kanzleramt mit der kanzlerin wo es
offenbar um die krone lage ging
inwiefern hat dieses treffen ihre
meinung oder ihren blick auf die korona
lage noch mal verändert oder hat sich
dann nichts mehr die kanzlerin ich haben
uns in der vergangenheit immer in einem
sehr engen austausch gefunden es ist
sehr gut dass das jetzt im übergang auch
weiter stattfindet und darum geht es
jetzt ja ganz konkret ich habe ja in
sehr präzise vorschläge gemacht über die
wir in den letzten tagen parallel zu den
koalitionsverhandlungen uns intensiv
unterhalten haben und die dazu beitragen
sollen dass wir diese lage die korona
lage in den griff bekommen und
selbstverständlich ist es das ansinnen
das ich habe und dazu sind auch gerade
diese gespräche wichtig dass die hier
vorgesehenen vorgehensweisen für die
zukunft schon jetzt schnell umgesetzt
werden denn wir brauchen tatkraft
jeder küche deutsche welle
deutschland steht zu seiner
verantwortung die wir haben im rahmen
der europäischen union wir sind das eine
große land mitten in europa das ganz
bestimmt den auftrag hat jeden tag dazu
beizutragen dass die europäische union
besser wird dass sie besser gelingt wir
sind nicht diejenigen die irgendwie am
rande stehen und kommentare verschicken
sondern wir sind diejenigen die mit dazu
beitragen wollen dass ein starkes
souveränes europa möglich wird und wir
wissen uns dort sehr eingebunden in die
transatlantische partnerschaft
insbesondere die zusammenarbeit mit den
usa ist für die künftige regierung von
zentraler bedeutung und das wird etwas
sein auf das wär was
auch die nächsten jahre weiter unsere
politik bestimmen wird die welt wird
sich verändern sie wird multipolar das
heißt es gibt viele starke staaten und
mächte in der welt die einfluss nehmen
auf das künftige geschehen nicht nur die
usa und china wie manche diskutieren
auch viele andere nationen des
aufsteigenden asiens korea japan vietnam
indonesien malaysia indien zum beispiel
stark gelände aus afrika und aus dem
süden amerikas werden ihre stimme
deutlich machen im hinblick auf das
künftige weltgeschehen und unsere
aufgabe ist dazu beizutragen dass es
eine multilaterale welt wird in der die
kooperation im vordergrund steht und wir
wissen dass wir alle für unsere
sicherheit gemeinsam verantwortung
tragen und das ist etwas was unsere
politik auch bestimmen wird und ein
aspekt ist immer wichtig was uns selber
ausmacht dass wir
demokratien sind dass wir für die
freiheit für das recht stehen das wird
natürlich auch eine rolle spielen denn
wir wissen uns mit einigen ländern zum
beispiel mit den vereinigten staaten
besonders verbunden weil uns diese werte
gemeinsam prägen
die nächste frage geht an herrn rinke
von mir aus gesehen links
und danach die kollegen die gerade den
herr scholz ich hätte eine frage an sie
zum auch zum thema europa schließt im
prinzip da an wo genau ist die
europapolitische koordinierung
verantwortung übernehmen sie das mit ins
kanzleramt sie haben das ja jetzt im
finanzministerium gemacht und was genau
heißt die formulierung dass die grünen
ein auswahl oder nominierungsrecht für
die eu kommission haben wenn es keine
deutsche
eu-kommissionspräsidenten gibt heißt es
dass ihre amtszeit auf jeden fall
begrenzt ist
eines ist ganz klar wir werden gemeinsam
europapolitik machen da wird es
verschiedene orte geben an dem das
geschieht bei den finanzministern wenn
die
wirtschaftsminister zusammen kommen wenn
die außenminister zusammen kommen das
kennen sie und das wird natürlich von
der regierung als gemeinsame politik
entwickelt ich jedenfalls wünsche mir
dass uns da sind auch die voraussetzung
zu beschaffen denn wir für folgende an
gemeinsamen kurs zu dem
koalitionsvertrag sehr genau und nehmen
können und im hinblick auf die frage wie
die personellen weichenstellung für die
zukunft beschrieben sind ist es doch
ganz klar wir haben jetzt eine regierung
gebildet aber wir haben auch einige
fälle für die zukunft mit beschrieben
und das ist so freundlich wie möglich
formuliert
patricia biene maja zdf hauptstadtstudio
ich habe die frage schon nach den
sondierungsgesprächen gestellt ich
wiederhole sie heute mit der hoffnung
auf eine antwort sie haben sich ja viel
vorgenommen sie haben gesagt es wird
richtig teuer sie müssen ganz viel
investieren gibt es inzwischen konkrete
zahlen wie viel investiert werden muss
und vor allen dingen wie genau sie das
finanzieren wollen
es ist wenn ich das vielleicht als
eingangs bemerkung machen darf aber da
sind wir viele hier mit dabei wir haben
uns vorgenommen dass das ein jahrzehnt
der investitionen wird das mit dieser
legislaturperiode und wir wollen ja auch
wieder gewählt werden mit der nächsten
legislaturperiode weitergeht da spielen
die investitionen eine zentrale rolle
die notwendig sind um den
menschengemachten klimawandel
aufzuhalten denn es ist ja auch zugleich
eine große industrielle modernisierung
die damit verbunden ist bei der
betrachtung der haushalts möglichkeiten
haben wir genau geschaut welche
entwicklung für die zukunft eintreten
können wir haben das aufgabenportfolio
betrachtet und wir sind sicher dass wir
all die investitions
fragen die in dem koalitionsvertrag
aufgeworfen werden in den nächsten
jahren auch beantworten können nämlich
mit der finanzierung der investitionen
soweit es sich um öffentliche handelt
ein großer teil dessen was geschieht ist
ja ohnehin privatwirtschaftliche sind
investitionen die wir dann begleiten
durch forschungsunterstützung durch
anreize am anfang einer veränderung und
natürlich wenn es um die infrastruktur
geht wo eine große modernisierung
notwendig ist da sind sich aber alle
einig ich glaube das kann man für den
künftig für die finanzen sagen das kann
man für die wirtschaft sagen und ich
würde deshalb vorschlagen dass
vielleicht herr lindner und habe da zwei
der bemerkung zu machen
ich muss dem nichts hinzufügen
also die antwort ist ja wir haben uns
das kleingedruckte wissen genau was wir
wollen wissen genau wie jus bezahlen
dann machen wir die nächste frage an
henry pinsky und dann der kollege auf
der seite
ins gesetz da einmal winken
hat sich dank eine frage an christian
linder unserer die drei außenpolitisch
relevanten ressorts sind ja nicht bei
der fdp gelandet auch bei der position
des kommissars oder der kommissarin hat
die fdp jetzt kein zugriffsrecht beim
finanzministerium natürlich schon
deswegen wäre meine frage ist das der
weg wo die liberalen dann sozusagen
außenpolitischen einfluss ausüben wollen
oder haben sie sich ganz bewusst er auch
die innenpolitischen themen fokussiert
die zukünftige bundesregierung
beabsichtigt ja kollegial
zusammenzuarbeiten die wesentlichen
leitlinien unserer gemeinsamen arbeit
wollen wir miteinander besprechen das
umfasst die innenpolitik das umfasst
natürlich auch den bereich der
internationalen verantwortung dieses
landes speziell
mit blick auf die fdp ressorts haben sie
zurecht dargestellt dass das
bundesministerium der finanzen jahr in
europa und der welt eng eingebunden ist
in abstimmungsprozesse der
ressortzuschnitt des bundesministeriums
der finanzen bleibt bestehen und
insofern gibt es darüber auch eine
möglichkeit das auf der internationalen
ebene die fdp weiter auch mit präsent
ist aber das will ich ausdrücklich
hinzufügen
ich glaube dafür alle zu sprechen eine
bundesministerin oder ein bundesminister
ist nicht der bundesminister der fdp der
spd oder der grünen eine
bundesministerin oder ein bundesminister
dient dem land
sebastian heinrich vom nach in potsdam
verhandelt sie haben vorhin gemeint sie
seien jetzt auf einem 15 grad fahrt mit
diesem koalitionsvertrag und haben dass
wenn ich sie richtig verstanden habe aus
dem steigenden preis der
emissionszertifikate abgeleitet
andererseits steht im koalitionsvertrag
die butterweiche formulierung
idealerweise zum kohleausstieg
idealerweise gelingt das schon bis 2030
wie schmerzhaft war das für sie herr
beck und frau berbalk diese formulierung
zu akzeptieren und an die anderen beiden
herrn scholz herr linder wie können sie
sozusagen den forderungen gerade junger
menschen damit im chat betreten die er
seit jahren für entschlosseneren
klimaschutz protestieren
ich hab das schon an anderen stellen
versucht zu erklären was ein sondierungs
kapiere ist ein junges papier ist ein
dokument des vertrauens nachweise ist
das gab es vorher gar nicht also im
politischen geschäft ein relativ neue
erfindung geboren aus einer zeit wo
parteien die klassischen politischen
lager überwinden müssen und man nicht
genau weiß was man sich da ein handeln
und umgekehrt genauso auch nicht genau
die partner dann ins gewissen wer da
eigentlich so kommt davon abgesehen dass
vielleicht die zeit vorbei ist wenn man
überhaupt noch von politischen lagern
reden kann siehe dem projekt folgen was
wir hier auftreten also ist das ein
jungtier in vieler hinsicht vage gewesen
und diese formulierung idealerweise gab
ein arbeitsauftrag für die
koalitionsverhandlungen und dieser
auftrag ist abgearbeitet worden so dass
jetzt im koalitionsvertrag im energie-
oder klimaschutz kapitel sehr präzise
maßnahmen beschrieben werden wie der
vierteilige kohleausstieg bis 2030
gelingen kann ich habe schon gesagt wenn
der co2 preis des mission handelns nicht
unter 60 euro fällt dann lohnt es sich
nicht mehr die kohlekraftwerke zu
betreiben
das ist sichergestellt dass es so kommen
wird und insofern ist das was unseren
jungs erklärt vielleicht noch vage war
neben anderen beispiel im
koalitionsvertrag jetzt sauber aufgelöst
und der nächste schritt ist dann eben
regieren und gestaltung der wirklichkeit
dass es dazu kommt
dann geschehen die kollegin linken
schulter sie war weil herr scholz und
ich auch angesprochen worden sind will
ich gerne kurz eine bemerkung machen
keine industrie nation wird größere
anstrengungen unternehmen beim schutz
des klimas
in der wirkung ist dieser
koalitionsvertrag das ambitionierteste
klimaschutzprogramm einer industrie
nation im grunde werden wir begrenzt
durch das was physikalisch und technisch
möglich ist
was politisch und ökonomisch erreichbar
ist ist in diesem vertrag geschrieben
und deshalb können wir gemeinsam vor die
jungen menschen treten die sie
angesprochen haben können sagen was
unternommen werden kann das werden wir
ins werk setzen und wir haben uns dabei
vorgenommen
diese große transformation zu erreichen
und zugleich
wohlstand beschäftigung und freiheit der
menschen zu erhalten wenn uns das
gelingt dann haben wir eine
verantwortung wahrgenommen die über uns
in deutschland hinaus reicht weil wenn
er mich dann ein pfad aufzeigen können
denen auch andere auf der welt
bestreiten
wird dem nicht viel hinzufügen aus
meiner sicht geht es um die größte
industrielle modernisierung deutschlands
seit weit über 100 jahren das ist ein
ehrgeiziges projekt das setzt den ausbau
der erneuerbaren energien in einem ganz
anderen tempel voraus als wir das bisher
gewohnt sind denn wir müssen die
bürgerinnen und bürger aber auch die
wirtschaft deutschlands mit der
notwendigen ressourcen nämlich strom aus
erneuerbaren energiequellen versorgen
das werden wir tun indem wir so
ambitioniert sind wie das hier gesagt
wurde und in dem koalitionsvertrag
detailliert beschrieben worden ist und
das wird auch die große aufgabe sein
denn wir müssen es hinbekommen dass wir
2045 klimaneutral wirtschaften aus
meiner sicht ist das gut für unser land
und gleichzeitig gut für die welt denn
wenn wir die technologien und die
fähigkeiten entwickeln die erforderlich
sind damit man wirtschaftlich
wettbewerbsfähig global wettbewerbsfähig
industrielle produktion betreiben kann
die gleichzeitig für das klima gut ist
dann ist das ein vorbild das andere
nachmachen können und das nicht dient
dann endgültig auch der den
anforderungen die der klimawandel an uns
stellt
jetzt wie angekündigt die kollegen mit
einer letzten frage vielen dank marina
komparative paris frau berg noch mal
eine frage zur außenpolitischen
koordinierung wir haben im laufe des
sommers gesehen irgendwelche verteilen
folgen ein mangel in der
außenpolitischen koordinierung haben
kann mit blick auf die ortskräfte in
afghanistan ich glaube die debatte über
einen nationalen sicherheitsrat dem
haben sie sich nicht angeschlossen
sprechen im koalitionsvertrag aber von
koordinierung was ist ihre antwort
darauf wird es mehr im kanzleramt geben
wird im auswärtigen amt mehr impulse für
eine in einer regierungs abstimmung in
außenpolitik geben
darf ich das
so beantworten wir es hier schon 23 mal
von geben und jeder von uns gesagt
worden dass es gibt eine bundesregierung
und wir werden gemeinsam handeln das ist
in allen feldern der politik der fall
auch im bereich der außenpolitik
ja ja schon jetzt auch ein
nationalen sicherheitsrat und wir haben
in diesem koalitionsvertrag das haben
wir für die klimapolitik deutlich
gemacht aber auch für die europa politik
sehr sehr deutlich gemacht die ja nicht
aus einem ressort heraus alleine betreut
wird und an querschnitts mäßig in allen
bereichen der nächsten bundesregierung
die das bisher auch schon der fall ist
verankert ist und so wird die
zusammenarbeit sowohl in europa politik
als auch in der gemeinsamen außen aber
eben auch wie sie angesprochen haben in
der sicherheitspolitik gemeinsam in
dieser koalition erfolgen
danke schön danke für ihre fragen es tut
mir leid dass sie nicht alle stellen
konnten wir haben die nächsten tage und
wochen sicherlich noch die gelegenheit
ihre fragen zu stellen und auch
antworten zu bekommen die
pressekonferenz ist jetzt beendet kommen
sie gut nach hause und büros tschüss
das war die pressekonferenz auf der spd
grüne und fdp ihren koalitionsvertrag
für die neue bundesregierung vorgestellt
haben wir werden gleich darüber reden
mit klimaschutz aktivistin luisa
neubauer mit professor karl rudolf korte
und
nicole diekmann aus unserem
hauptstadtstudio ist auch noch bei uns
ich möchte erstmal mit professor karten
noch mal ganz kurz reden weil dir
nämlich noch weitere termine und weg
muss professor korte vielleicht eine
ganz kurze einschätzung von ihnen wie
haben sie das jetzt alles atmosphärisch
wahrgenommen das wirkt er ja sehr
getragen ja er sehr ernst von so einem
aufbruch spirit trucker wir machen das
jetzt wie man es schon bei anderen
pressekonferenzen dann erlebt hat für
neue regierung da war jetzt nicht so
viel zu spüren
ja das ist animiert jetzt nicht zur
fackel umzügen wie das 1998 zum teil der
fall weil die große inszenierung als
medienspektakel einer
koalitionsvereinbarung rot grün das ist
es nicht aber das zeigt den einstieg
auch dass man praktisch noch mal ein
punkte programm entwickelt sich als zur
politischen führung in der pandemie
bekennt dieser wolle jetzt übernehmen
will und auch klar macht dass man ein
krisenstab gründen möchte mit
expertenrat kombiniert in der tat hatten
wir nicht den eindruck dass es an einem
strang bisher geht was die
krisenbekämpfung anbelangt und das ist
auch eine frage wie man vielleicht am
ende über geschäftsordnung hinaus in dem
grundgesetz vorsieht ein ja ein
katastrophenschutzgesetz was zu einen
krisenstab möglich macht immer befristet
immer parlamentarisch mandatiert aber
diese instrumentalen die wir zuletzt
erlebt haben über die
abstimmung mit dem ministerpräsidenten
das kann es ja nicht sein insofern ist
der ton gesetzt durch die krise und dann
wird der ton aufgenommen in ein völlig
neues modell das regieren da ist schon
sehr viel neu da ist viel auch an
beschreibung wie man lernen
zusammenfindet und auch die grundmelodie
der klimaneutralität die sich durch alle
kapitel hindurchzieht ist dort sehr
authentisch dargestellt war sich sie
durchaus dass das eine eine sehr
begründete neuanfang ist weil es nicht
um reparaturarbeiten in dieser
gesellschaft geht das reicht offenbar
nicht sondern ist ein neues angriffs
modell gerade zu einer lernenden
gesellschaft einer lernen politik die
davon ausgeht die unterschiede zu
belassen und deshalb gemeinsam
wahrscheinlich auch gering wird in
kabinettssitzung als das bislang der
fall war um dann eine gemeinsame
gestaltung daraus zu machen so
politikverständnis neu nicht politik als
problemlösung sondern politik als
gestaltungsauftrag das durchzieht diese
pressekonferenz insofern ist es in der
tat eine zäsur und
damit wollen wir sich verabschieden am
bedanken uns sehr dass sie zeit für uns
hatten und werden uns mit sicherheit bei
der einen oder anderen politischen
analyse wiedersehen vielen dank
professor pater der gehört
ja
nicole diekmann
ich bin froh dass du noch bei mir bist
ich hoffe das wunderbar
ich brauche ja noch jemanden der mit mir
die ganze sache durchgeht und zwar werde
jetzt wirklich wahnsinnig viel gehört
lasst uns vielleicht einmal ganz kurz
von anfang an bedenken beginnen olaf
scholz hat ja mit sehr sehr ernsten
worten zur pandemie im panini lage in
deutschland begonnen was denkst du warum
warum wurde das wirklich an den anfang
dieser pressekonferenz gesetzt
die intensivstation sind mittlerweile am
limit das krankenhaus system ist an
einigen stellen im land schon überlastet
patienten patienten werden um verlegt
und das wort von der triage geistert
hier immer wieder durchs land das heißt
die vierte welle ist das heißt sie ist
noch nicht weiter punkt angekommen aber
sie ist schlimmer als die drei zu
vorigen und zudem gab es schon in den
vergangenen wochen kritik an der ampel
die noch gar nicht im amt ist da haben
sich viele
gewünscht dass da schon führung
übernommen wird in einer solchen
ausnahmesituation in einer solchen
dramatischen situation in der
deutschland im moment steckt und diese
kritik scheint olaf scholz scheinen die
ampel koalition ihre aufgenommen zu
haben das ist das eine signal dass
ausgehen sollte von den äußerungen und
auch von den ankündigungen die schweiz
die ja eben gemacht hat unter anderem
krisenstab im kanzleramt soll
eingerichtet werden
es soll ein pflege bonus geben eine
milliarde soll dafür zur verfügung
gestellt werden ist ging aber noch ein
anderes signal von diese presse von
dieser pressekonferenz aus und das wird
sowohl von spd fdp als auch von grünen
nicht beabsichtigt gewesen sein es war
aber unübersehbar
man ist jetzt schon in der position das
auslaufen der epidemischen lage von
nationaler tragweite dass man mit dem
gesetz als ampel das war letzte woche
beschlossen hat besiegelt hat auch daran
gibt es viel viel kritik darauf hat sich
interessanterweise auch die erste frage
eines journalisten bezogen nach der
vorstellung des koalitionsvertrages das
heißt man ist bevor man überhaupt die
verantwortung schon übernommen hat
sowohl als regierung als auch eben für
die bekämpfung von corona das brechen
der vierten welle ist man schon in der
position verteidigen zu müssen was man
beschlossen hat das ist keine gute
ausgangslage
dann gehen wir jetzt vielleicht mal ein
paar punkte durch lasst uns mal auf den
zuschnitt der ministerien schauen das
gesundheitsministerium das bleibt jetzt
wohl doch bei der spd so steht es im
koalitionsvertrag ist es ja im vorfeld
mal die fdp bekommt und irgendwie hieß
es das wollte niemand haben
genau das hat sich ja als eine art
schleudersitz herausgestellt gerade in
dieser pandemie also das ist im moment
das wichtigste ressort wahrscheinlich da
gucken alle drauf da kann man sehr sehr
viele fehler machen und macht die dann
auch hier einsparen noch
geschäftsführender gesundheitsminister
der cdu
hatte keinen leichten job und stand sehr
viel in der kritik in den vergangenen
monaten mit seinem pandemie management
genau und wie du es gerade gesagt hast
das bisschen was raus gelangt ist an
informationen aus diesen
koalitionsverhandlungen ist die info
dass sich da niemand wirklich darum
reist um dieses ressort oder scholz
wollte jetzt eben auch nicht verraten
wer es denn bekommen solle meine
kollegin hauptstadtstudio britta
spiekermann hat danach gefragt da sagte
scholz
wir warten jetzt erstmal den parteitag
ab am ersten dezemberwochenende halten
ja fdp und auch spd-mann parteitagen um
den koalitionsvertrag dann partei intern
abzustimmen und erst dann wolle man
wirklich preisgeben werden dieses amt
besitz ist die frage hat man noch
niemanden gefunden hat sich noch niemand
gefunden oder geht es tatsächlich jetzt
erstmal darum gestrickte reihenfolge
einzuhalten
zu dieser personalie haben wir natürlich
auch eine frage auf facebook nämlich
ganz klar die frage wenn das
gesundheitsministerium jetzt bei der spd
ist wird lauterbach gesundheitsminister
wie stehen da seine chancen überschätzt
also wenn man die sozialen netzwerke
fragt dann stehen seine chancen
tausendprozentig dann ist er quasi
gesetzt als gesundheitsminister die
sozialen netzwerke werden aber selten
gefragt und da hört man aus der spd dass
naja karl lauterbach
ja auch immer wieder in den vergangenen
jahren kritik auch an olaf scholz geübt
hat dass der sehr sehr oft genervt war
von karl lauterbach ob das jetzt eine
kategorie sein sollte bei der besetzung
eines solchen postens lassen wir mal
dahingestellt aber so gesetzt wie das
viele kommentierende auf twitter
instagram und anderswo gerne sehen so
gesetzt ist lauterbach nicht aber klar
der name kursiert aus guten gründen den
wir die liste noch mal weiter durch da
wird es auch ein neues ministerium für
bauen und wohnen geben das geht auch an
die spd ja was soll dieses ministerium
leisten
mieten erschwingliche mieten sind ja ein
riesiges thema leider in den vergangenen
jahren geworden und ist weiterhin ein
sehr dringendes thema weil die mieten in
vielen städten explodieren und
das wohnen ein riesiger kostenfaktor
wird und nun hat jetzt da wurde eben
sehr konkret angekündigt dieses neu
geschaffene ministerium soll
400.000 wohnungen im jahr bauen
hunderttausend davon in öffentlicher
hand also für noch erschwinglichere
mieten das ist das was man sich jetzt
als zielmarke gesetzt hat um den markt
zu stabilisieren
ok klimaschutz ministerium reden wir
dann gleich mit luisa neubauer und
wir müssen auch darüber reden welches
ministerium ist nicht geben wird nämlich
das für digitales konnte sich die fdp
nicht durchsetzen
tja das hat sich schon relativ früh
abgezeichnet das handelsblatt wusste da
ziemlich früh bescheid muss man mit
allem respekt vor den kolleginnen und
kollegen da sagen die offizielle ausrede
ist beziehungsweise begründung ist man
habe kein geeignetes ministerium
beziehungsweise gebäude hier in berlin
gefunden für ein solches ministerium
und es sei auch wahnsinnig schwer so
etwas aufzubauen naja das ist bei jedem
ministerium so bauen wird ja jetzt auch
geschaffen
ich weiß nicht ob die fdp sich da nicht
durchsetzen konnte es gibt die frage
immer wieder die ist hochumstritten
braucht es dafür einen eigenen eigenes
ministerium oder nicht wie viel macht
hätte jemand in diesem ministerium
beziehungsweise wäre das problem eines
solchen ministeriums nicht dass man
daneben quasi für sich abgeschottet da
sitzt und die anderen ministerien dieses
sogenannte querschnittsthema nicht
mitdenken es ist jetzt angesiedelt bei
verkehr das wird spannend verkehr und
digitales soll an die fdp gehen da geht
auch schon annahme um die in berlin
sollte es anders sein volker wissing von
der fdp soll das bekommen sagen wir mal
so es kann ja nur besser werden
namen gab es ja heute keine opfer jetzt
olaf falls der ist ja gesetzt so ein
paar
wissen wir auch schon die geister herum
oder meinen es zu wissen wie du sagst
wissen
was welche namen geistern doch noch zum
rauchen es gab eben einen interessanten
moment da wurde nämlich christian
lindner gefragt warum sich denn die fdp
die ja vier ministerien bekommen soll
kein außenpolitisch relevantes gesichert
habe ob das absicht sei oder ein preis
den man zahlt und da bezog sich dann
christian lindner auf das
finanzministerium in dem er sinngemäß
sagte na ja also
finanzministerium habe ja durchaus auch
außenpolitisch etwas mitzureden und
damit hat er indirekt erstes bestätigt
dass dieses ministerium an die fdp geht
und es wäre jetzt eine riesige
überraschung eine sehr riesige
überraschung wenn lindner diese
ministerium nicht verstehen würde das
war immer klar es ist ein großer traum
er will dieses ministerium haben und im
grunde haben wir in diesem moment gehört
dass er es wohl bekommen wird und
was würdest du jetzt sagen wenn du diese
pressekonferenz und das natürlich am
jetzt die seiten des koalitionsvertrages
noch nicht wort für wort durchgearbeitet
dafür war die zeit zu knapp aber was
würdest du insgesamt sagen welche
handschrift trägt diese koalition jetzt
welcher partei genau deswegen würde ich
das nicht machen wir haben gerade eine
pressekonferenz gehört und da geht es
erstmal darum das habe ich auch vor der
pressekonferenz schon gesagt sich als
geschlossen zu präsentieren man steht
gerade ganz am anfang man will etwas
schaffen man will auch über diese vier
jahre hinaus die ja für eine
legislaturperiode folge sind an der
macht bleiben und regieren und da wäre
man jetzt gekniffen da wäre man mit dem
klammerbeutel gepudert
zu jetzt schon gräben zu signalisieren
beziehungsweise sich auch zu versuchen
zu profilieren auf kosten der anderen
das war heute nicht der tag dafür dafür
sind die nächsten vier jahre noch zeit
genug deswegen kann ich ohne diesen
koalitionsvertrag der ich glaube 177
seiten habe ich eben gesehen ich schaue
das noch mal eben nach
gelesen zu haben dass tatsächlich
nicht seriös sagen also das ist
tatsächlich eine lesart oder eine
exegese 177 seiten nicht schlecht das
kann man heute das kann ich in diesem
moment noch nicht sagen gut dann geben
wir dir gerne zeit bis das durch
gearbeitet hast noch eine andere frage
es stehen große projekte an die kosten
richtig viel geld aber so richtig ist
über dieses finanzierungsfrage heute
doch nichts bekannt geworden
das stimmt auch da hat eine meiner
kolleginnen aus dem hauptstadtstudio
nachgebohrt patricia wiedemeier die hat
es schon nach den sondierungsgesprächen
versucht und gefragt na ja sie haben
sehr viel vor sie haben viele projekte
die sie uns hier ankündigen woher soll
das geld kommen und wie viel soll das
alles eigentlich kosten darauf hat sie
heute darauf haben wir alle heute wieder
keine konkrete antwort bekommen da sind
sowohl olaf scholz auch als auch
christian lindner und auch robert habeck
ausgewichen man habe das durchgerechnet
sagte man nur und man wisse das sei
durchaus zu finanzieren
und jetzt schaue ich gerade mal ob wir
noch eine
frage haben ämter gewinner wollen wir
jetzt nicht beantworten weil wie gesagt
da müssen wir jetzt nur noch abwarten ja
da gibt es vielleicht noch mal so um
dieses thema soziale gerechtigkeit was
ja auch ein ganz großes thema für die
spd natürlich war da schreibt halligalli
auf youtube 12 euro mindestlohn ist gut
aber insgesamt zu wenig um den
sozialstaat zu stärken na ja das ist
natürlich nicht der einzige punkt der
heute im zusammenhang mit sozialer
gerechtigkeit genannt wurde
interessanterweise war das ein stichwort
das auch von christian lindner kamen der
natürlich versucht jetzt dieses
soziale kälte image das der fdp anhaftet
auch loszuwerden es ging da auch um
bildung und bildungsaufstieg um eine
kindergrundsicherung die da auch im
koalitionsvertrag steht die da
beschlossen werden soll also es
erstreckt sich natürlich nicht auf 12
euro mindestlohn auf die die spd aber
sehr sehr stolz ist dass sie das
durchgesetzt hat denn das war eine
konkrete forderung im wahlkampf und
zwölf euro sind so konkret wenn man wenn
man vorher sagt 12 euro und hinterher
stehender 12 euro ist das politisch
gesehen natürlich die beste die beste pr
die man haben kann
jetzt ist es ja so dass es bei spd und
fdp noch mal parteitage geben wird wo
eben über den koalitionsvertrag
abschließend entschieden wird bei den
grünen sollen die mitgliederinnen und
mitglieder abstimmen digital erwartest
du da noch irgendwelche größeren
widerstände ich glaube dass man sich
intern immer wieder rückversichert hat
dass das jetzt am ende nicht noch platz
es wird sicherlich die ein oder anderen
stimmen geben aus den parteien die sich
noch mal kritisch zu wort melden werden
profilierung ist in der politik sehr
wichtig und es ist auch immer wichtig
auch auf koalitionspartner weiter druck
auszuüben für die nächsten vier jahre
und weiter zu signalisieren dass man
selbstbewusst ist
überraschungen kann man selten erwarten
südlich der natur der sache ich würde
jetzt erst mal davon ausgehen das geht
jetzt weiter seien gegangen
nicole danke für den moment du bleibst
immer noch weiter bei uns ich würde aber
jetzt gerne frage ist computer
klimaschutz aktivistin luisa neubauer zu
uns in die runde holen hallo frau
neubauer schön dass sie bei uns sind
mit ihnen wollen wir natürlich über die
klimaschutzpläne der neuen regierung
reden und sie haben auch schon im
vorfeld gesagt dass er sich da wirklich
große sorgen machen wie bewerten sie das
jetzt
[Musik]
in deutschland erleben und die regierung
friedensplan der von tinte nicht
ausreicht das heißt nicht dass da nicht
einzelne sachen drin sollen zb nicola
stieg der ein historischer erfolg für
die klimabewegung sind aber wir sind
nicht hier für 1 in der folge sahen
dafür thema gerechtigkeit und ein zimmer
vom staat politik und das haben wir
immer noch nicht
ich frage sie ganz konkret was hätte aus
ihrer sicht jetzt noch drin stehen
müssen damit man da in sachen
klimaschutz aus ihrer sicht wesentlich
voran kommt
na ja zunächst einmal fängt damit an
dass man sich als regierung ein co2
budget geben muss und dass man sich
halten muss das ist wie internationaler
klimaschutz organisiert sein muss
das heißt dass man auf einmal konkret
wird in der art und weise wie manche
zwei reduziert man fängt an
tatsächlichen gas ausstieg zu skizzieren
einer zeit jedoch realistisch ist man
wird konkret bei autos und verbrennen da
gibt's ja eine reihe von punkten bei dem
jetzt auch expert überall sagen hey
leute dass es überhaupt nicht konkret
genug ist es vage und an vielen punkten
merkt man einfach dass dort der etwas
ziemlich hat das tor verlängert wird und
klima gerechtigkeit auf der strecke
bleibt
[Musik]
erneuerbaren bei ihnen im hintergrund
wird protestiert ihre mitstreiterinnen
und mitstreiter am und was fordern sie
naja die neue regierung sagt mehr
fortschritt wagen wir werden halt sagen
mehr klimagerechtigkeit wagen das hier
ist ein tool das ist nicht ein probelauf
diese regierung probiert und wenn dies
nicht hinbekommt 15 grad macht die nixe
das ist die letzte und einzige regierung
die das noch packen kann und wir müssen
wir den höchsten ansprüchen an die
regierung rangehen und da reicht es
nicht zu sagen ja letztes mal was
irgendwie noch schlechte zahlen wir
einen guten schritt nach vorne gemacht
diese regierung muss sich an dem
orientieren die musste ich an dem messen
lassen was notwendig ist für die inhalte
lebensgrundlagen für den erhalt von
gegenwart und zukunft und das ist was
wir deutlich machen dieser
koalitionsvertrag
ist in sachen kohleausstieg ein
riesenerfolg für uns nach 154 noch ein
klima streiks aber das reicht das nicht
genau dazu vielleicht noch die info
hinterher gereicht dass sie eben von
diesem convention center stehen wo die
pressekonferenz jetzt gerade
stattgefunden hat ich habe fragen für
sie auf facebook george fragt haben sich
die grünen eigentlich überhaupt irgendwo
durchgesetzt nur so wir wollen ja bis
2030 ist ja wohl ein witz klimaschutz
jetzt sagt er
[Musik]
dass man dadurch die grünen fragen das
finde ich ist nicht angemessen von mir
zu beantworten wir sehen aber auch und
das ist eben immer noch ein bier das in
dem man politisch dem krieg gegen diese
aufbereitet als der kinder ist es eine
verantwortung der grünen alle parteien
haben gesagt 15 grad politik oder alle
parteien haben das gerade mit diesem
koalitionsvertrag verpasst und das geht
nicht an dem wir alle gleichermaßen die
chance und wir können es natürlich auch
denken werde mehr blockiert als die
anderen ich habe noch eine weitere frage
auf youtube für sie da schreibt ein user
im ernst klimaschutzes super aber wenn
wir so weitermachen wie es geplant ist
dann geht es mit deutschland back up und
china und indien werden unsere industrie
übernehmen was sagen sie diesen user
[Musik]
sommer auch im aartal wie viele menschen
hat gesehen dass eine einzelne flug dort
um zerstörung angerichtet hat was
passiert wenn wohlstand über jetzt
zehnter arbeit wurde in wenigen stunden
die straße runter gespielt wurde und
dass man es geschafft hat den menschen
so glaubhaft zu verkaufen dass das
eigentliche problem klimaschutz ist und
nicht die katastrophe vor der wir uns
jetzt ist es eine riesen industrie
erfolg ein riesenerfolg der fossilen
lobbys und derjenigen die uns immer
weiter die klimakrise eintreiben wollen
aber stimmt den faktor mensch wir müssen
uns bei einer lebensgefährlichen
menschheit gefährden katastrophenschutz
mit allem was wir haben und selbst die
studierenden florians industrien bringen
uns nichts wenn unser grund und boden
keine sichere grundlage mehr für uns
sein kann und wer ist höchste zeit dass
wir das ernst in mutters annehmen und
das sage ich auch mit besten grüßen an
die neue regierung
das geht mir gerne weiter luna fragt auf
youtube
und fragte sie ob sie glauben dass das
zusammenspiel zwischen sozialer
gerechtigkeit und klimagerechtigkeit
funktionieren kann
naja
also wer die pressekonferenz eben
verfolgt hat gemerkt wir euphorisch von
wachstum durch innovation gesprochen
wurde und dass die worte gerechtigkeit
und nachhaltigkeit extrem
genannt wurden im vergleich wir sagen er
ist die mächtigkeit bewegung ganz
deutlich klima und gerechtigkeit gehören
zusammen die klimakrise allein ist die
größte ungerechtigkeit der welt und wir
müssen sie bekämpfen indem die gerechte
maßnahmen umsetzen und es liegt
natürlich in der macht der neuen
regierung das zusammenzubringen aber sie
können auch wie die letzte regierung
wird weitergehen oder aufspielen das ist
die gestaltung frage und das ist aber
auch was die straße treibt weil wir eben
sagen nee so läuft ich mich leute und
wenn es eins ist wenn dieser
koalitionsvertrag 1 ist dann zeigt er
das klima gerechtigkeit handarbeit ist
die großen erfolge der cola steht 20 30h
ständig drin steht der der zaghafte
versuch einige dörfer zu schützen obwohl
es nicht reicht das sind die erfolge der
klimagerechtigkeit bewegungen und wie
sie werden die letzten die jetzt
aufhören würden im gegenteil wir am
kohleausstieg erkämpft und jetzt kämpfen
wir 15 grad politik und zwar nicht
gerecht
es wird zum ersten mal ein ministerium
für wirtschaft und eben klimaschutz
geben welche erwartungen vom lehn sie an
dieses ministerium
na ja die letzten 40 jahre extrem
erfolgreich klimaschutz behandelt wie so
nachmittags problem um das man sich
kümmert wenn man mal gerade lust und
zeit hat oder sonst irgendwie ähnlich im
weg stehen darf man die wirtschaft
stärken muss und das muss aufhören und
wir haben keinen geringeren anspruch
daran als die wirtschaft kommt plötzlich
abonnieren und 215 jahren das ist was
wir laut dem pariser vertrag machen
müssen als deutschland und dass unsere
verantwortung der wir auch gerade
übrigens bei der klimakonferenz und
glasgow er wieder rechenschaft getragen
haben
jetzt sieht alles danach aus dass dieses
ministerium eben an die grünen geht wie
ist das für sie und ihre bewegungen
gehen sie davon aus dass sie da dann
halt auch einfach einen direkteren draht
hin haben werden um eben ihre ihre ziele
durchsetzen zu können oder ein mehr
gehör erfahren
also zunächst einmal würden wir uns
freuen wenn sich die ministerin minister
die zukünftigen ist und wenn es da
selbstständig um ihre eigenen klimaziele
kümmern das ist ja nicht irgendwie unter
wunschdenken was jetzt neuer bischof
minister für uns ein stück wald politik
macht sondern das ist was er selbst der
republik den wählerinnen und wähler und
der internationalen gemeinschaft
versprochen hat es wäre also was mindest
dass man selbst auf dem hahn kommt und
wie im letzten drei jahre ohne irgendein
draht irgendein ministerium nicht davor
gescheut klima gerechtigkeit zu kämpfen
und das werden wir genauso weitermachen
und es ist immerhin schon ein großer ein
großer gewinn dass wir nicht mehr das
gefühl haben müssen in jedem ministerium
schweren mensch darum die die klimakrise
als gefahren frage stellen aber wir
machen uns auch keine vorhalten das wird
richtig hart werden dass werden richtig
hat vier jahre werden wir werden um
alles in der welt kämpfen dass wir
nehmen hier nichts geschenkt und der
koalitionsvertrag in all seinen vagen
formulierung in all den ausweichen und
all den runter gewaschenen sozusagen
sätzen deutlich schon sehr sehr gut an
auf was wir uns einstellen müssen
nämlich auf eine politik der schönen
worte bei der wir maßnahmen einfach
kämpfen müssen ich habe noch eine frage
von max auf youtube der möchte nämlich
wissen wie groß wäre denn die globale
auswirkungen wenn es deutschland
gelingen würde co2 neutral zu werten
dass leute überall auf uns gucken und
die fragen sich was macht deutschland
eines der reichsten privilegien an der
welt was machen wir unser verantwortung
und wir sind ja ein vorbild so oder so
entweder geben wird allen an einer
ausrede nichts zu tun oder wir zeigen
wie es anders gehen kann und sie ein
globales gerechtigkeit verständnis
aussehen kann und das kann welten
bewegen und ich war selbst bei der
klimakonferenz in glasgow und habe
gesehen was passiert wenn deutschland
eben genau das nicht macht und
enttäuscht hinter dem versprechen
zurückbleibt und das kann wir umdrehen
und das müssen wir auch umdrehen denn
wie gesagt ist es noch den will das ist
keine probe das ist nicht eine weitere
regierung die man probieren kann ob die
klimaschützern kriegt dass es die letzte
regierung dennoch 15 grad umsetzen kann
und wir haben den letzten drei jahren
bewiesen wo die macht und die kraft mit
blick auf der straße bei den leuten den
ich locker lassen und in dem sinne von
wir gerade erst an
ich habe noch eine letzte ein letztes
statement von doug farbe auf youtube der
schreibt wir fahren die sache mit dem
klima sowieso gegen die wand das war
schon vor jahren klar das heißt eine
sehr pessimistische und vielleicht auch
ein bisschen resignierter haltung was
was sagen sie solchen leuten die sagen
es war schon zu spät
naja zum einen ist ja nicht darum dass
wir ja irgendwie das klima retten wenn
wir das nicht schaffen es alles verloren
wir kämpfen um jedes zehntel grad wir
kämpfen dafür dass ebensoviele wie
möglich lebensgrundlagen erhalten
bleiben dass die welt so sicher und so
gerecht wie irgend nur irgendwie möglich
ist und dieser kampf den kann man an
keinem punkt wir verloren erkämpften
erklären so lange es noch eine einzige
art gibt die wir zu schützen haben ein
ökosystem eine region wo menschen leben
eine heimat wo menschen gerne alt werden
wollen und auf der anderen seite kann
ich leute beruhigen wenn es mit dem
klima komplett nach hinten losgeht da
machen wir immer noch im besten fall
stellte die sauberer sind und
lebenswerter sind straßen die besser zu
nutzen sind moritz konzepte für alle
eine nachhaltige landwirtschaft die fair
bezahlt und und und also das ist eben
genau das wofür wir einstehen zimmer
gerechtigkeit das ist eine
art vermehrung von wola gehen für alle
und im besten falle sorgen wir eben auch
dabei dafür ja dabei dafür dass die
lebensgrundlagen erhalten bleiben die
klimakatastrophe geschwächt wird aber
ich möchte ihnen ganz herzlich danken
dass sie sich zeit für uns genommen
haben und vielen dank für diese
einschätzung machen sie es gut
[Musik]
ja und wir jetzt immer noch bei mir es
ist nicht weil diekmann im
hauptstadtstudio berlin und niki ich
möchte diese sendungen werden jetzt
wahnsinnig viel gehört wahnsinnig viele
informationen aufgenommen und sortiert
und eingeschätzt und analysiert ich
möchte ich als letzte frage die mir
kennen mich richten was sie als
hauptstadtkorrespondent in auch so ein
gespür dafür wie die stimmungslage dann
in so einem regierungsviertel insgesamt
ist war das jetzt heute kommt er jetzt
ein großer aufbruch oder ist das eben
eher so gedämpft
ich würde sagen das ist zweigeteilt es
gibt jetzt einmal diesen ich nehms man
überbau diese nächsten vier jahre
gesellschaftspolitische fragen
klimapolitische fragen
ein
neues deutschland dass man da ja quasi
heute
vorgestellt hat dass man sich vorstellt
das scheint aber noch in weiter ferne
nicht nur deshalb weil ja noch niemand
vereidigt ist weil das in der nikolaus
woche passieren soll sondern auch weil
das hat man ja heute auch
chronologischen aufbau dieser
pressekonferenz gesehen weil im moment
das alles beherrschende thema corona
alles die vierter werden und ich glaube
dass jetzt erst mal darauf geschaut wird
wie sehr geht man da jetzt in die vollen
wie sehr gibt man jetzt gas tut man das
endlich fragen sich ja viele als ampel
gibt man da jetzt endlich gas und ich
glaube tatsächlich dass jetzt erst mal
sehr an der tagespolitik
gemessen wird wie handlungsfähig und wir
entschlossen und auch wie mutig ist
dieser ampel ist die im zweifel
olaf scholz hat sich heute eine
hintertür offengelassen
auch in der lage
[Musik]
entscheidung nochmals zu revidieren er
hat nämlich heute auf den 9 dezember
geschaut auch ein wichtiges datum auch
in der nikolaus woche da schreiben sich
nämlich bund und länder zur nächsten
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz und man
hatte sich bei der in der vorherigen
woche als man sich darauf geeinigt hat
auf maßnahmen darauf nochmal wiederum
geeinigt auf eine sogenannte
evaluations klausel das heißt am 9
dezember noch mal zu schauen ist das was
bisher beschlossen ist eigentlich
ausreichend für diese dramatische lage
in der wir uns gerade befinden also
langer rede kurzer sinn im moment gibt
es jetzt erstmal so gut wie nur corona
es gab viel viel versprechendes heute in
den äußerungen es gab tatsächlich
aufbruchstimmung wenn auch gedämpft dem
der lage eben im moment angemessen aber
erstmal schauen wir jetzt wie
entschlossen man sich gegen die vierte
welle stellt und wie geschlossen auch
und darauf werden wir sehr sehr genau
schauen vielen dank nicole diekmann für
die letzten zwei stunden miteinander
verbracht haben ich danke dir viele
grüße nach berlin danke sehr gerne
ja und auch ihnen vielen dank für fragen
und kommentare wir sehen uns bald wieder
biss dann schönen abend noch schießen